hello everyone today we're going to be
talking about the atomic bombings of
hiroshima and nagasaki during the second
world war
and let's start today by telling a story
so at the conclusion to the second world
war japan
though their military forces had been
soundly defeated
stubbornly refused to negotiate an end
to the conflict
their militaristic leaders had committed
to total war in defense of the japanese
empire
and were prepared to mobilize japanese
civilians to
combat any potential american invasion
president harry truman and his advisors
were therefore faced with a difficult
choice
either they could commit to a long and
costly invasion of japan which they
estimated would kill more than a million
people
or they could use their secret weapon
the world's first
nuclear bombs which the united states
had recently constructed
so in order to shorten the war and avoid
the need for an invasion
truman decided to drop two bombs on
hiroshima and nagasaki two major
military and
industrial targets demonstrating the
extent of the japanese military's desire
to keep fighting however
even after these bombs were dropped
japan's supreme council remained
deadlocked with some military leaders
still refusing to consider negotiating a
peace
it took the unprecedented intervention
of emperor hirohito to break the impasse
in the council and finally convinced the
military to stand down
bringing an end to the war so that's
quite
a simple story there and presented like
this
dropping the nuclear bombs was pretty
unambiguously the right
and moral thing to do when compared to
the worst alternative anyway
what this is is a basic trolley problem
you might not like dropping the nuclear
bombs but if the only other option on
the table is a long
costly invasion that is definitely going
to kill and injure even more people
then the bombs become acceptable and
justifiable
and this is a popular and enduring
perception of the events that led to the
nuclear bombs being dropped that they
were used specifically to force japan to
surrender
without the need for an invasion however
this is fleet admiral william d leahy
who was the senior most united states
military officer on active duty during
world war ii
and the personal chief of staff to
presidents franklin d roosevelt
and harry s truman and after the war
with regards to the nuclear bombs
lee hee wrote the following it is my
opinion that the use of this barbarous
weapon at hiroshima and nagasaki was of
no material assistance in our war
against japan
the japanese were already defeated and
ready to surrender because of the effect
of sea blockade and bombing with
conventional weapons
fleet admiral chester w nimitz who was
commander-in-chief of the u.s pacific
fleet during world war
ii said at a speech given on october 5th
the japanese had in fact already sued
for peace before the atomic age was
announced to the world with the
destruction of hiroshima
and before the russian entry into the
war the atomic bomb played
no decisive part from a purely military
standpoint
in the defeat of japan and this is
general dwight
eisenhower who was supreme commander of
the allied expeditionary force in europe
during world war ii and later president
of the united states
and his opinion of the atomic bomb was
that the japanese were ready to
surrender
and it wasn't necessary to hit them with
that awful thing
and eisenhower later wrote in his
memoirs about a conversation he had with
war secretary henry stimson
in which he states i voiced to him my
grave misgivings
first on the basis of my belief that
japan was already defeated and that
dropping the bomb was completely
unnecessary
and secondly because i thought that our
country should avoid shocking world
opinion by the use of a weapon whose
employment was
i thought no longer mandatory as a
measure to save american lives
it was my belief that japan was at that
very moment
seeking some way to surrender and in
1944 president roosevelt directed henry
stimson to put together a survey team to
write a report on the effectiveness of
the allied aerial bombing tactics during
the war
published in 1946 this strategic bombing
survey came to the conclusion that japan
would have surrendered even if the
atomic bombs had not been dropped
even if russia had not entered the war
and even if no invasion had been planned
or contemplated
so what's going on here then the people
i just quoted there were all involved in
the second world war in
important positions of political and
military power
and instead of viewing the bombs as a
necessary lesser of two evils
they instead see them as everything from
simply militarily unnecessary
to a grave moral crime now obviously if
these people are correct that the
bombings of hiroshima and nagasaki were
not necessary to end the war
then the trolley problem version of the
story we told at the start of the video
can't be true
can it so this is what we're here to
investigate today
which of these versions of history is
closer to the truth
we're going to take a look at the
closing months of the second world war
in the lead up to the atomic bombings
and i think we should start today by
briefly introducing the various people
that we're going to be talking about
a few of whom we've mentioned already so
first off in the united states we have
president franklin d
roosevelt who was in office for most of
the second world war
roosevelt died on april 12 1945
meaning that his vice president harry
truman became president
and he was in office for the remainder
of the war including the period when the
nuclear bombs were dropped
working for truman we have chief of
staff admiral william d
leahy who was one of the people we just
quoted who thought the bombs were
unnecessary
secretary of war henry l stimpson who
was the person to whom eisenhower voiced
his misgivings about the bomb
and secretary of state james f burns and
spoiler warning this man in particular
makes a lot of very poor decisions
leahey and stimson both served in the
same roles under roosevelt but james
f burns was appointed secretary of state
by harry truman on july 3
1945. the nuclear bombs themselves were
constructed by the manhattan project
which was directed by general leslie
groves
and the actual laboratory that designed
the bombs was headed by j
robert oppenheimer over in japan at the
top of the japanese government we have
emperor hirohito
and he was advised by the supreme
council for the direction of the war
the supreme council had six members and
they for the most part
fell into two factions the moderates and
the hardliners
so for the moderates we have prime
minister kantaro suzuki
minister of foreign affairs shigenore
togo and minister of the navy
mitsumasa yonai and for the hardliners
we have minister of war karachika anami
chief of the army general staff
yoshijiro umezu
and chief of the navy general staff
seremu toyoda we'll get more into the
differences between these groups in a
little while but generally the
hardliners favored a more
hard-line military strategy and the
moderates were more
moderate also important for us here is
now
take a sato the japanese ambassador to
the soviet union who was in frequent
contact
with minister of foreign affairs
shigenori togo
and the messages sent between togo and
sato are key to understanding the
thinking of the japanese leadership at
the time
outside of the us and japan we have
british prime minister winston churchill
and premier of the soviet union joseph
stalin i don't know
if you've ever heard of them now of
course there were many more people than
this
involved in the end of the second world
war and i'll be mentioning more people
going forward
this list comprises only the most
principal actors in the particular
events that we're going to be talking
about today
as well as people there's going to be a
lot of dates and events to remember here
so i'm going to be using a calendar
going forward so that we can keep track
of everything
the two atomic bombs were dropped on
hiroshima and nagasaki on the 6th
and 9th of august respectively and we've
also already mentioned the inauguration
of harry truman on the 12th of april and
his appointing of james burns to
secretary of state
on the third of july as we go through
the events leading up to the bombings
i'll add more to this calendar and
highlight which days i'm talking about
in particular
and hopefully this will help us to keep
organized before all that though there
is one
important event we need to know about
prior to the second world war
and that's the russo-japanese war fought
between 1904
and 1905 now i won't dwell on this too
long but the very quick
wikipedia summary goes like this the
russo-japanese war was fought between
the russian and japanese empires over
rival imperial ambitions in manchuria
and korea so it's two empires fighting
over land and influence in asia
basically
anyway in this war russia suffered a
series of humiliating and surprising
defeats at the hands of japan a nation
that russia was expecting to beat
relatively easily
perhaps most notable of these defeats is
the battle of tsushima where virtually a
whole russian fleet was sunk by the
japanese navy
who suffered only minor losses
themselves russia was forced to sue for
peace which was mediated in the united
states by president theodore roosevelt
and the resulting treaty saw russia
withdrawing their troops from manchuria
recognizing japan's claim to korea as
well as seeding a bunch of territory
all this coupled with the fact that the
japanese empire had initiated the war
with a surprise attack on the russian
occupied port arthur
meant that the russians were to put it
lightly rather ticked off about the
whole affair
the disastrous russian performance in
the war is considered one of the main
instigating factors behind the 1905
russian revolution
but that's a story for another day so to
summarize
and generalize a bit russia held a
grudge against japan for beating them in
a war and denying them influence and
territory in
asia this is all important in the
context of the yalta conference which
took place between the 4th
and 11th of february there this was a
meeting of stalin churchill and franklin
d
roosevelt to discuss among other things
the post-war reorganization
of europe nazi germany was on its last
legs at this point its defeat was
inevitable
adolf hitler shot himself on the 30th of
april and the german high command
surrendered unconditionally on may the
7th
and the yalta conference was held to
discuss and negotiate the various things
that should happen
following that upcoming nazi defeat the
main focus of the conference was
europe but important for us here is that
the soviet union's entry into the war
against japan was discussed
churchill and roosevelt wanted stalin to
declare war on japan
specifically they wanted him to invade
japanese occupied manchuria
which would make japan have to fight on
an extra front and spread their
resources thinner
and this would hopefully hasten their
defeat now this was a little bit awkward
as russia and japan had signed a
non-aggression pact in 1941
and that wasn't due to expire until 1946
despite this non-aggression pact stalin
also wanted russia to declare war
against japan
however he wanted something in return so
on the 11th of february the allies
signed a secret protocol
agreeing that russia would enter the war
against japan quote two or three months
after germany has surrendered and the
war in europe is
terminated and the price for russia's
doing so was that the former rights of
russia violated by the treacherous
attack of japan in 1904
shall be restored and then they're all
listed there
so basically stalin was asked to declare
war on japan
after the war in europe was finished and
he said okay but we want back all the
stuff that japan pinched off us back in
1904.
churchill and roosevelt's agreed and so
the deal was made
and this deal was kept secret for a few
reasons
mainly because russia is very big it was
going to take quite a bit of time for
the soviet union to transfer military
forces from the west to the east
and they didn't want to risk tipping
japan off to the impending invasion of
manchuria before it was ready to go
ahead
president roosevelt for his part thought
this was a fair deal
he later stated that the russians quote
only want to get back
that which has been taken from them
however james burns then acting as
adviser to roosevelt at yalta
worried that the more the united states
asked of the soviet union
the more they would demand in return
writing in his memoirs after the war
burns makes it clear that he thinks too
much was conceded to the russians at
yalta
although he is careful to give reasons
as to why he thinks the late president
roosevelt made the decisions he did
burns does point out however that at the
time the terms of the secret protocol
were decided upon
he didn't know about them and thus had
no influence over them because
he was not secretary of state mr
stetinius was
secretary referring to edward stetinius
jr who was roosevelt's
secretary of state at yalta this is
important for us here because although
truman kept on other of roosevelt's
staff after his death
he chose to replace stetinius feeling
that too many concessions had been made
to the soviet union
at yalta and his new pick for secretary
of state was
james burns a choice which signals a
change towards a more aggressive stance
with regards to russia
which leaves the united states in a bit
of an awkward situation diplomatically
speaking
under the previous president and
secretary of state they'd signed a
secret agreement with the soviet union
assuring them various concessions in
exchange for going to war against japan
but then that president died and his
secretary of state was replaced
and the incoming president and secretary
of state aren't at all as keen on
conceding anything to
the russians and i wonder if that's
going to cause any problems
down the line so let's leave the allies
in their awkward situation there and
discuss what the japanese government was
up to during this time
and to oversimplify a little uh
throughout this whole period
the japanese leadership had basically a
single main
aim and that was to avoid having to
accept an unconditional surrender
and instead achieve a negotiated peace
the supreme council in japan knew that
they couldn't win the war but they
wanted peace on terms that they could
negotiate
nazi germany of course was forced to
accept an unconditional surrender by the
allies
unconditional surrender here meaning
surrender without any guarantees being
made to the losing side
and japan was very keen to avoid a
similar fate
the main sticking point was the question
of japan's imperial institution
and the fate of the emperor in
particular the emperor was more than
just a regular old leader
in japanese society he was a revered
quasi-divine figure of particularly
special importance
and with his position as the head of the
japanese government
and importantly the japanese military
japan accepting
unconditional surrender meant that the
emperor could then conceivably be
arrested and tried for war crimes and
possibly even
executed this was something that
brigadier general bonner fellas when
advising general macarthur described as
comparable to the crucifixion of christ
to us the united states was very aware
of the special position of the emperor
and the gravity of the question of what
should be done with him but we'll get to
that a little later
now there were disagreements in japan's
supreme council about what exact
peace terms they should attempt to
negotiate on the more pessimistic
or realistic end of the scale we have
japan just getting out of the war
however they can
with the preservation of the imperial
institution so basically accepting
whatever peace terms are offered
so long as they guarantee the emperor's
position
and on the more optimistic or
unrealistic end of the scale we have
japan getting out of the war while
securing the preservation of the
imperial institution
securing the preservation of japan's
military forces
avoiding a foreign occupation
maintaining japan's occupied overseas
territories and
ensuring any trials for japanese war
crimes were carried out
by japan now this was all never going to
happen obviously but it was argued for
the hardline militarists on the council
were very keen on the preservation
of the military believe it or not
holding out for these terms was
obviously a desperate
long shot but these were equally
desperate men regardless of these
disagreements though the supreme council
was unified on the first point
they were absolutely not going to lose
the emperor and therefore they want to
avoid an unconditional surrender
at any cost and they pursued this goal
both militarily and
diplomatically and let's talk about
military strategy first
so the militarists on the supreme
council favored a strategy of making the
war
so difficult for the allies that they
would lose their taste for unconditional
surrender and decide to negotiate peace
rather than fight on for another year or
so at huge cost to themselves
so japan wasn't going to win the war
they knew that
but they were going to end it on terms
that were more acceptable to them
the council anticipated an upcoming
allied invasion of japan and planned to
throw
everything they had at it including
civilians
in order to wear down the allied will to
fight and thus secure
better terms a similar situation played
out in miniature on the island of
okinawa now okinawa was occupied by the
japanese military
and when the u.s military invaded it
local inhabitants of the island
including children were conscripted by
the japanese military and sent to die by
the thousands
and by the time okinawa was captured by
the allies on july the 2nd
both the japanese and u.s militaries had
lost considerable amounts of lives and
military equipment it was both a very
costly loss
and a very costly victory president
truman for his part was very concerned
about the losses at okinawa and feared
that committing to a full invasion of
japan could mean quote
an okinawa from one end of japan to the
other
so that's the supreme council's military
strategy there
diplomatically the council's plan was to
convince the soviet union to mediate a
peace between japan
and the other allies much like the
united states that mediated peace at the
end of the russo-japanese war
japan was counting on the pact of
neutrality they had with the soviet
union
to keep the russians out of the war they
hoped that they would have a better
chance at securing favorable peace terms
if they had the soviet union backing
them up and in exchange for helping them
with negotiations the japanese
leadership was prepared to offer stalin
various territorial concessions from
their empire
now unfortunately for the japanese
people both the military and
diplomatic strategies of the japanese
leadership were
to put it bluntly rubbish to take the
diplomatic strategy first
in trying to persuade stalin to help
them out they were bargaining from a
position of weakness
they had nothing to offer the soviet
union that it was not in a position to
just take
for itself stalin didn't want the war to
end before he'd had the chance to invade
and recapture the territory that had
already been promised to him
at the altar conference so why bargain
with japan in exchange for helping them
when you could just invade them and take
whatever you like
stalin wanted to be in at the kill as he
put
it and he wasn't about to grant japan a
stay of execution
to accomplish this impossible diplomatic
task minister of foreign affairs
shigenore togo
sent frequent messages to japan's
ambassador in moscow
naotake sato instructing him to somehow
convince the russians to help japan
broke a piece now sato was rather a lot
more realistic than his colleagues back
in tokyo
he knew the russians he realized that
the council's plan was almost certainly
not going to work
and he didn't mind telling them in a
series of
increasingly frank messages sent in
response to togo's instructions
sato attempted to make his superiors see
sense
and let's quote a few of his cables here
it seems extremely unlikely that russia
would flout the anglo-americans and the
opinion of the entire world by
supporting japan's war efforts with
either moral or material means
i believe in the long run japan has
indeed no choice but to accept
unconditional surrender or terms closely
equivalent
i believe that stalin feels there is
absolutely no necessity for making a
voluntary agreement with
japan on this point i see a serious
discrepancy between your view
and the actual state of affairs which is
a wonderfully insulting line
togo however didn't appreciate his
subordinates candor
he responded to one of sato's complaints
quote
in spite of your views you must carry
out your instructions
endeavor to obtain the good officers of
the soviet union in ending the war
short of unconditional surrender and
this
is the general pattern of communication
that went on between the two
togo asked sato to do the impossible
sato attempted to explain that it was
impossible
togo told him to shut up shut your face
just do it anyway please thank you and
it's worth noting here that the allies
had cracked the japanese communication
codes and were freely reading japan's
messages so they were privy to all of
this information
as well as togo and sato's back and
forth comedy routine they were working
on
now militarily the strategy of the
supreme council was just as ill-fated as
their diplomatic efforts
expecting the opposing side to lose
their nerve and call it quits faster
than you
when it's your territory being invaded
and occupied
is quite a risky strategy it's also a
strategy that hinges on the enemy first
doing something that you expect them to
do that being here to invade japan at
all
an allied invasion of japan was not
guaranteed to happen
the united states was working on plans
to possibly invade japan should it be
necessary
but we should not make the mistake of
thinking that because an invasion was
being planned for
that it was an inevitability president
truman wrote in his diary on the 17th of
june
shall we invade japan proper or shall we
bomb
and blockade and this is before the
trinity test before truman knows that he
has nuclear bombs to work with
or the effectiveness of those nuclear
bombs before that
he's presenting an invasion as only one
possible way forward
at the start of the video i quoted
several u.s
military leaders who thought japan would
have surrendered prior to an invasion
being necessary
regardless of the use of nuclear bombs
for example
admiral leahy who described japan as
already defeated
and ready to surrender but just how
defeated was
japan let's briefly talk about the state
of the japanese military
so firstly by the middle of 1945 the
japanese navy was
virtually non-existent every japanese
aircraft carrier had been either sunk
or disabled hundreds of warships had
been destroyed
and after the united states captured
okinawa japan's few remaining
battleships were either decommissioned
or used as stationary anti-aircraft
platforms
because japan simply lacked the fuel to
keep them moving
outside of suicide attacks by small
vessels the japanese navy had ceased
to exist and that's not a rhetorical
flourish by me there that's a quote from
the us
summary report of the pacific war in the
air japan was faring no better
there was a shortage of bombers fighters
trained pilots materials to construct
aircraft out of
and fuel to keep them in the air as
you'll probably be aware by the end of
the war japan was resorting to suicide
missions carried out by poorly trained
pilots instructed to simply crash their
planes into enemy ships
due in part to the rushed training of
the pilots and the increasingly poor
construction of the aircraft
they were flying fewer than a fifth of
these planes actually hit their targets
on the other side the united states air
force was conducting constant bombing
raids on targets inside japan
basically as it pleased meeting little
to no resistance in the air
general curtis lemay the man in charge
of america's air offensive against japan
later claimed that he did not lose a
single b-29 bomber to japanese fighters
and to quote the strategic bombing
survey i mentioned near the start of the
video
united states planes crisscrossed the
skies with no effective japanese air or
anti-aircraft opposition given its
collapse both in the air
and at sea a naval blockade was able to
be put in place around japan
which firstly was absolutely devastating
for the japanese economy
almost their entire merchant fleet was
picked off and destroyed and
imports of vital resources like coal
crude oil iron ore
and rubber stopped as a result many
japanese ports
such as the one at hiroshima simply
ceased to operate
the blockade also had the effect of
dramatically reducing the scattered
japanese ground forces ability to
communicate
resupply and redeploy without their navy
japan's troops were increasingly
under-supplied as well as stranded
wherever they happened to be
so given the absolutely dismal state of
the japanese military situation
it is presumptuous if the supreme
council to assume that the united states
had to commit to a costly ground
invasion at all
the americans could if they wanted to
simply maintain their naval blockade and
bombing campaign and there would be very
little that the japanese leadership
could do about it
they were counting on the united states
first launching an
invasion and only then losing faith in
it
of course another possibility is that
the united states could decide they
didn't want to do a ground invasion
before they'd started one which is of
course what happened
but we're getting a little ahead of
ourselves there now it is clear from
their awful
unsalvageable military situation that
japan's leaders
should have surrendered much sooner than
they did
and indeed some wanted to but so long as
the hard-line militarist faction in the
supreme council
insisted on continuing the war there was
little that those who desired peace
could do about it
directly anyway behind the scenes
members of the japanese leadership who
realized that the war
needed to be finished were working on
plans to that end
but we'll get to those in due time for
now though the supreme council remained
deadlocked
and the terribly sad thing about all
this is that while the leadership of
japan waited uselessly for
either an american ground invasion or
rescue from the soviet union
their civilian population centers were
being systematically destroyed
and here we need to introduce the
concept of strategic bombing
that being the intentional targeting of
enemy cities with
area bombing grades with the aim of
destroying the enemy's morale
and industry now strategic bombing is
interesting in that its name changes
depending on who is doing it to whom
when we're doing it to them it's called
strategic
or morale bombing and it's a calculated
emotionless tactic intended to bring a
swift
end to the war by breaking enemy morale
and disrupting their war industry
when they're doing it to us on the other
hand it's called
terror bombing and it's a cowardly
despicable tactic intended to instill
fear in the population by the ruthless
slaughter of innocent women and children
it all depends on your points of view
really the strategy of indiscriminate
area bombing had been used prior to
world war ii
but it was during the war that it really
got up to speed
the nazis were targeting civilians with
bombs from the very start of the war
and notably one of the aims of their
blitz bombing campaign against cities in
the united kingdom
was to break the morale of the british
civilian population
the british royal air force began the
war favoring precision
tactical bombing strikes against
specific targets
but they soon got with the times and
adopted an area bombing strategy against
german cities one of the aims of which
was to break the morale of the german
civilian
population and there were two main
branches of thinking behind making
civilians the target of bombing raids
there's the material reasoning and the
psychological reasoning
and we'll talk about the material
reasoning first
so why spend time and resources trying
to exclusively bomb small
mobile military targets that can fight
back
when you can just fly behind those
targets and bomb the factories and
shipyards that are producing them
and those factories and shipyards
supplying the military they're staffed
by
civilians who usually live in nearby
houses
they're also culpable to some degree for
keeping the war machine going right
and if we bomb them there will be fewer
workers to work at those factories and
therefore will reduce the enemy
countries production
and end the war quicker so it's not that
we want to bomb civilians you see
it's simply that we think this will be
less painful in the long run
now cities aren't solely comprised of
war factories and
worker housing of course but all the
other things in the city
the non-military industries that keep
those workers alive
the hospitals that heal them when
they're sick and injured
the schools that educate their children
all these things are connected
in varying degrees to the functioning of
that society's capacity for war
so following this logic you can just
bomb
everything by in effect reclassifying
everything in the city as a military
target
once you've done this bombing civilians
is impossible
because there are no civilians the city
is just one big military installation
now it is worth noting here that the
united states did not
enter the war with this mindset in 1939
president roosevelt sent an appeal to
refrain from air bombing of civilians to
various countries
and that reads as follows the ruthless
bombing from the air of civilians in
unfortified centers of population during
the course of hostilities which have
raged in various quarters of the earth
during the past few years
which has resulted in the maiming and in
the death of thousands of defenseless
men women and children
has sickened the hearts of every
civilized man and woman
and has profoundly shocked the
conscience of humanity
if resort is had to this form of inhuman
barbarism during the period of the
tragic conflagration with which the
world is now confronted
hundreds of thousands of innocent human
beings who have no responsibility for
and who are not even remotely
participating in the hostilities which
have now broken out
will lose their lives i am therefore
addressing this
urgent appeal to every government which
may be engaged in hostilities
publicly to affirm its determination
that its armed forces
shall in no event and under no
circumstances
undertake the bombardment from the air
of civilian populations
so some very high-minded words from a
leader
not yet in the war there a few years
later however the united states was in
the war and its military leaders saw
things
a little differently and to quote
general curtis lemay
there are no innocent civilians it is
their government and you are fighting a
people you are not trying to fight an
armed force anymore
so it doesn't bother me so much to be
killing the so-called
innocent bystanders lemay's bombing
strategy proceeded exactly as if he
really believed there were no innocent
civilians in japan
once allied bombers were able to reach
japan mass fire bombings of japanese
population centers began
killing and displacing hundreds of
thousands of civilians
the firebombing of tokyo on the 9th and
10th of march killed an estimated 100
000 people by
itself and made a million more homeless
so in the course of just a few years the
bombing of innocent civilians went from
inhuman barbarism to there are no
innocent civilians
civilians were just another military
asset to be bombed as far as the allied
air force was concerned now the other
line of reasoning for strategic bombing
was the possible
psychological effects that would result
from the bombing of civilian population
centers
those being that perhaps the population
would lose faith in their government
or the soldiers on the front lines would
be demoralized by their families and
homes being bombed while they were away
and all this would therefore lead to an
increased likelihood
for the enemy to surrender and the
material reasoning for the bombing was
often used merely as a pretext for this
actual psychological aim winston
churchill left this slip in a memo he
drafted on the 28th of march in which he
addresses the controversial bombing of
dresden which took place between the
13th
and 15th of february in this memo
churchill says
it seems to me that the moment has come
when the question of bombing of german
cities
simply for the sake of increasing the
terror though
under other pretexts should be reviewed
otherwise we shall come into control of
an utterly ruined land
the foreign secretary has spoken to me
on this subject and i feel the need for
more precise concentration upon military
objectives such as oil and
communications behind the immediate
battle zone
rather than on mere acts of terror and
wanton destruction
however impressive so bombing
simply for the sake of increasing the
terror though
under other pretexts so you're bombing
civilians to break enemy morale and if
anyone gets squeamish about that you say
oh don't worry i know we hit a few
schools and hospitals there but we were
actually aiming at that factory a few
streets over that makes
boots for the army or something every
city had some finger other in it that
supported the armed forces in some way
and thus there was always a handy excuse
for indiscriminately area bombing
anywhere now this strategy is and
was at the time very controversial not
just from a moral standpoint i mean
that's obvious you're blowing up
innocent people but it was also
controversial in terms of its
effectiveness
and first let's talk about the
effectiveness of area bombings material
goals
firstly even with the enormous amount of
bombs which were dropped on nazi germany
the country's production actually
increased throughout the war and this
happened for a few reasons
one of which was that nazi germany used
millions of people as slave labor
many german factories were staffed by
prisoners
when you're a fascist regime occupying
whole other countries
lives are very cheap also whatever
damage was done to german
industry during indiscriminate area
bombing raids on cities was relatively
minor
because to quote the strategic bombing
survey
as a rule the industrial plants were
located around the perimeter of german
cities and characteristically these were
relatively undamaged
now you could say nazi germany's
production would have increased further
without the area bombings of course but
we're not talking about reducing
production then we're talking about
slowing down the increase of production
which is less likely to be a major
contributing factor to a surrender
we also have to consider here that while
your air force is bombing civilian
housing with the aim of breaking their
morale
they're not bombing other things which
it might be more useful to bomb
the strategic bombing survey concludes
that allied bombing raids on for
instance the nazis oil refineries and
transportation network
were key to hastening the end of the war
in particular it caused the targeting of
germany's railways and waterways the
decisive blow that completely
disorganized the german economy
it also concludes that the importance of
careful selection of targets for
air attack is emphasized by the german
experience
the germans were far more concerned over
attacks on one or more of their basic
industries and services
their oil chemical or steel industries
or their power or transportation network
than they were over attacks on their
armament industry or the city areas
so the specific targeting of key
industries and transport networks was
more effective than
indiscriminate area bombing and the
destruction of civilian housing
basically
next let's talk about the psychological
effectiveness of area bombing the
thinking that area bombing would lead to
a surrender caused by a breakdown in
morale
turned out to have a few flaws firstly
on the government end
militaristic totalitarian fascist
regimes
don't care about the opinions or
well-being of their civilians
so they're not likely to throw in the
towel just because lots of ordinary
people are getting killed or injured or
made homeless
they don't care about that caring about
people is not high on the list of
priorities for totalitarian
fascist regimes on the civilian end
there's several reasons why trying to
break their morale didn't lead to the
end of the war
you know beyond their governments not
caring what they think
firstly as much as people might be
terrorized by indiscriminate bombing
raids
they were also already being terrorized
by their own governments and the police
force of those governments
it's one thing to have your morale
shaken and decide things would be better
if hitler was gone
and it's another thing to translate that
into action
and go and fight the gestapo someone
might not like having their city bombed
and their house burnt down
but that doesn't necessarily mean
they're gonna go out and rebel against
the government and risk being
executed this is arthur harris perhaps
better known as
bomber harris who was the
commander-in-chief of raf bomber command
during the height of the second world
war
and he oversaw the united kingdom's area
bombing campaign against german
cities including the bombing of dresden
now as you might be able to tell from
his nickname
bomber harris was a very enthusiastic
supporter of
area bombing and he was also a very
enthusiastic supporter of being honest
about the point
of area bombing and let's read a quote
of his from 1943
the aim of the combined bomber offensive
should be unambiguously stated as the
destruction of german cities the killing
of german workers and the disruption of
civilized life throughout germany
the destruction of houses public
utilities transport
and lives the creation of a refugee
problem on an unprecedented scale and
the breakdown of morale both at home and
at the battlefronts by fear of extended
and intensified bombing
are accepted and intended aims of our
bombing policy
they are not byproducts of attempts to
hit factories
so when he said this he was clearly in
favor of area bombing as a tactic
and also in favor of being honest about
the aim of it
the point was to disrupt civilian life
kill people
and spread fear however after the war
bomber harris changed his mind in his
1947 book
bomber offensive harris writes that
while in 1941
it had seemed like a good idea to use
area bombing to break the enemy's morale
in the long run it proved to be wholly
unsound
and i quote when we had destroyed almost
all the larger industrial cities in
germany the civil population remained
apathetic while the gestapo saw to it
that they were docile
and insofar as there was work left for
them to do industrious
morale bombing was comparatively
ineffective against so well organized a
police state as germany
the german leaders themselves admitted
after the war that morale was bad after
our attacks on their towns
but they distinguished between the
morale and the conduct of the workers
conduct they say was unaffected in other
words there was nothing
unarmed germans could do about it with
the gestapo standing by
and with the concentration camp round
the corner
so that's the failure of morale bombing
from someone who was previously both
very in favor of it and directly
responsible for it there
and the strategic bombing survey also
covers the same topic
saying if they that's the german
civilians
had been at liberty to vote themselves
out of the war they would have done so
well before the final surrender
in a determined police state however
there is a wide difference between
dissatisfaction
and expressed opposition about the
nicest thing
you can say about this morale bombing
idea is that some people apparently
thought it might work
but it didn't and it just so happens
that in the course of it not working it
pointlessly killed
injured and displaced a very large
number of innocent civilians
attempts to break the morale of the
german citizenry with terror-bombing
tactics led to
apathy not revolutionary action and not
to get to
armchair general on you all here but i
don't mind concluding that every single
bomb that was dropped on a german house
would have been better put to use if it
was dropped instead on a german railway
line
or something else of actual military
significance
however i would like to make clear here
that by no means am i saying we should
absolve the entire german citizenry of
all fault in the second world war many
civilians were of course committed
supporters of the nazi party and often
participants in its various crimes
when i say innocent civilians i
absolutely do not mean those people
however many german citizens were
innocent
many were persecuted by the nazis
themselves or
many were children for instance and
sadly indiscriminate area bombing does
not descend
between these groups of people now all
this is important for us today
because the manner in which the atomic
bombs were targeted and used was merely
an extension of
this morale bombing philosophy so let's
talk a little about that
in the months before the atomic bomb was
used a group of scientists and military
personnel dubbed the targets committee
was established by director of the
manhattan project general leslie groves
and this group met several times to
discuss how the bombs
should be used and the minutes of the
meetings of the target committee give us
an
insight into the thinking behind the
target selection for the bombs
on the 10th of may the group met in the
office of j robert
oppenheimer who was the head of the
laboratory that designed the bombs and
one
of the scientists on the committee and
they discussed various points relating
to how the bombs should be used
one key point for us here is the section
psychological factors
in target selection and that reads as
follows
it was agreed that psychological factors
in the target selection were of great
importance two aspects of this are one
obtaining the greatest psychological
effect against japan
and two making the initial use
sufficiently spectacular
for the importance of the weapon to be
internationally recognized when
publicity on it
is released so when picking targets here
they're not just thinking about the
psychological effects upon the
inhabitants of japan
they're also already thinking about the
effects the bomb will have
outside of the war they want the bomb to
be sufficiently
spectacular like they're setting off a
big firework or something
furthermore still under the
psychological factors heading
regarding hiroshima it was put forward
that
hiroshima has the advantage of being
such a size and with possible focusing
from nearby mountains
that a large fraction of the city may be
destroyed
that's an advantage remember so in
picking hiroshima as a target they were
aiming to destroy
a large fraction of the city due
specifically to the associated
psychological factors
reading these minutes it is clear that
the members of the target committee were
much
more focused on the psychological
effects of the bomb than its practical
physical effects upon japan's military
capabilities
regarding this they write use against
military
objectives nice use of quotation marks
there it was agreed that for the initial
use of the weapon
any small and strictly military
objective should be located in a much
larger area subject to blast damage in
order to avoid
undue risks of the weapon being lost due
to bad
placing of the bomb so they didn't want
to bomb an isolated
strictly military target for fear of
missing and losing the weapon
whereas if they dropped a bomb on a city
missing their air quotes
military target is just fine because a
large fraction of the city will
still be destroyed regardless and
therefore the bomb will still convey
the very important psychological effects
now i don't know any way of reading this
other than it's okay if we don't
actually hit a military objective
so long as we still hit a city actual
material effects upon japan's military
capabilities were clearly not of prime
importance here
it is very telling that the top of their
target list was kyoto the former capital
of japan which was of relatively little
military significance
but enormous psychological importance
they also include the ludicrous
reasoning that since kyoto is an
intellectual center for japan
the people there are more apt to
appreciate the significance of such a
weapon
as if the inhabitants of the other
cities of japan would be simply too
unintelligent to understand the
significance of their city being
exploded in the end of course kyoto was
not hit with an
atomic bomb general leslie groves wanted
very much to bomb kyoto but after a lot
of stalling
it was reluctantly taken off the list of
targets on the persistent
and repeated orders of secretary of war
henry stimpson who
and yes this is the actual reason once
went there on holiday
at a meeting of the interim committee on
the 31st of may stimson described kyoto
as
exclusively a place of homes and art and
shrines and argued
it must not be bombed the minutes of
this meeting on the 31st of may reveal
the confusing and
contradictory list of requirements for
the bomb targets
and let's read a little from the section
effect of the bombing on the japanese
and their will to fight
after much discussion concerning various
types of targets and the effects to be
produced the secretary expressed the
conclusion
on which there was general agreement
that we could not give the japanese any
warning
that we could not concentrate on a
civilian area but that we should seek to
make a profound psychological impression
on as many of the inhabitants as
possible now this doesn't make a whole
lot of sense
if you aren't concentrating upon a
civilian area
how do you make a profound psychological
impression upon as many inhabitants as
possible
it's not going to make much of an
impression on the japanese population if
you drop the bomb on some isolated
military targets somewhere where no one
will see it
it would just be one more thing that got
bombed that day
this was brought up in the meeting when
someone quote pointed out that one
atomic bomb dropped on an arsenal would
not be much different from the effect
caused by any air core strike of present
dimensions
however dr oppenheimer stated that the
visual effect of an atomic bombing would
be tremendous
it would be accompanied by a brilliant
luminescence which would rise to a
height of 10 to 20
000 feet so that's the key thing here
that's supposed to differentiate the
nuclear bombs from the conventional
bombing raids it's not the material
effect upon japanese military
capabilities
it's how impressive they look now of
course if you want to create
a profound psychological effect with
your big impressive looking bomb
you need to drop it somewhere where
people can see it
so how do you drop the bomb on a
strictly military target
while ensuring there are lots of
japanese inhabitants around
to see how tremendous it is the members
of the meeting wriggled their way out of
this conundrum with the following
euphemism
the most desirable target would be a
vital war plant employing a large number
of workers
and closely surrounded by workers houses
so we're not bombing a civilian area to
be clear we are not aiming at
houses we're aiming at a factory closely
surrounded by houses
and if we happen to miss the factory
that's okay we won't lose the bomb
because it will still destroy a large
fraction of the city remember
but again we're not targeting the
civilians
we promise what a load of rubbish
honestly they want to bomb civilians
they have decided to bomb civilians and
they know it
but they're too cowardly to admit it so
they're pretending the desired effects
of the bomb will merely be the byproduct
of an attempt to hit a factory as bomber
harris put it
now secretary stimson went along with
this ridiculous euphemism or at least
contented himself with having saved his
pet city of kyoto
the other target cities were placed on a
no bomb list meaning that they were not
to be targeted by the air force with
conventional bombings prior to being hit
with the atomic bombs
this was because another desired
attribute of the potential bomb targets
was that they were
as far as possible undamaged so as to
better demonstrate the destructive power
of the atomic bomb
they want a spectacular show after all
now this requirement speaks to the
relative military
unimportance of the cities that ended up
making the list
they were thus far undamaged in part
because they were not
high priority military targets this is
something for us to keep in mind when
considering those justifications for the
atomic bombs that highlight whatever
military
industry existed in hiroshima and
nagasaki
because whatever military industry
existed in those cities did so
specifically because they were not being
attacked
initially because of the city's relative
unimportance compared with higher value
bombing targets
and following that because they were on
this no bomb list
allied bombers had attacked dozens of
japanese cities with conventional
weapons
tokyo was extensively fire bombed months
before the atomic bombs were dropped
there was nothing stopping allied
bombers from also attacking the list of
target cities if they were supposed to
be so important to japan's military
efforts
except for the fact that they were being
preserved on purpose
to be destroyed with atomic bombs now of
course before the bomb was used in the
field it was first
tested and the timing of the first
nuclear test detonation
codenamed the trinity test caused a
problem for president truman
as the upcoming potsdam conference in
germany meant that he personally would
be out of the country
truman actually wanted to delay the
potsdam conference until a little while
after the trinity test so that he would
know
going into diplomatic negotiations there
whether or not he had the nuclear bombs
to play with
but he had to settle for getting the
news while he was at the conference
now before we get into talking about the
potsdam conference i'd just like to
recap what our principal actors are up
to here
so truman was stating his intent to get
russia to commit
to the japanese war and he later wrote
that it was his main objective
in going to potsdam the soviet union was
ignoring japan's peace feelers
and per the secret agreement they made
at yalta preparing to void
the non-aggression pact they had with
japan and invade manchuria
japan was organizing a diplomatic
mission to travel to moscow and meet
with stalin directly in order to
hopefully convince him to negotiate an
end to the war
this diplomatic mission was led by
prince fumimaro kanoe
now kanoe was a prestigious politician
and former prime minister who
prior to the war had advised against
attacking america
he thought pearl harbor was a mistake
and he was very critical of the hardline
militarists
stating in a report to the emperor in
february of 1945 that they were the
greatest obstacle to a termination of
the conflict and that
even though they knew they would lose
they are likely to continue fighting to
the very end
merely to save face so the selection of
this
chap to head the diplomatic mission to
russia sends a clear message here
the emperor wants the war over and he
wants to send kanoe to talk to stalin to
get it done
to prepare for the arrival of this
mission togo messaged sato to set up a
meeting between kanoe and stalin
and sent ahead the text of a message
from the emperor himself that kanoa was
to bring with him
and this message reads as follows his
majesty the emperor
mindful of the fact that the present war
daily brings greater evil and sacrifice
upon the peoples of all the belligerent
powers
desires from his heart that it may be
quickly terminated
but so long as england and the united
states insist upon unconditional
surrender the japanese empire has no
alternative but to fight on with all its
strength
for the honor and existence of the
motherland now
stalin got this message but made no
immediate response
he too was heading to the potsdam
conference and that's what we're going
to talk about next
so the potsdam conference took place
between the 17th of july and the 2nd
of august now this conference was
similar to the altar conference in that
it was a meeting of the leaders of the
soviet union united kingdom and united
states to discuss various matters
related to the post-war organization of
europe
however in the time between the two
conferences a few important things had
changed
firstly as we've mentioned the u.s
president and secretary of state had
changed and truman and burns wanted a
harder line on russia
we don't need to get too deep into it
here but negotiations with the soviet
union regarding various matters related
to europe had become
increasingly difficult plus the nazis
were out of the war by now
which meant there was less incentive for
the other allies to concede to stalin's
demands
another important change was the
completion of the nuclear bomb
project the trinity test was conducted
early in the morning on the 16th of july
just
prior to the potsdam conference and the
test was a success the manhattan project
scientists demonstrated that they could
detonate
a nuclear bomb now though the leadership
of the united states had intended to get
the soviet union into the war against
japan
all the things we just mentioned
contributed to an important shift in
opinion on that issue that was going on
behind the scenes
and two diary entries written by
president truman at potsdam make
clear this shift in opinion the first
comes on the 17th of july when truman
met stalin for the first time
and they discussed various matters
including russia's entry into the war
against japan
truman's diary account of the
conversation reports that stalin will
quote
be in the japanese war on august 15th
finney the japanese when that comes
about
although truman uses a free letter
shorthand for
japanese that i won't repeat here on
account of it being a racial slur
so the indication from this diary entry
on the 17th of july is that truman
thinks that japan
is close to being finished off and that
soviet entry
into the war is what is going to do it
and he furthermore wrote a letter to his
wife while at potsdam stating
i had gotten what i came for stalin goes
to war on august 15th with no strings on
it
and he goes on to mention how this means
he thinks the war will be shorter and
fewer lives will be lost
as a result so truman seems positively
enthusiastic about soviet entry into the
war right here
and it is interesting to note that
truman's belief that japan would be
finished off by a soviet declaration of
war
means that he already thinks a u.s
invasion of japan
is unnecessary the second entry into
truman's diary i want to talk about
comes the very next day
now truman had been informed of the
success of the trinity test already on
the 16th of july
but it's here on the 18th that he first
gets an indication of just how powerful
the atomic bomb was
henry stimson received a coded message
describing an explosion that could be
seen for hundreds of miles
and he relayed this to truman who he
described as greatly reinforced
and highly delighted upon hearing the
news
and writing in this diary on this day
truman says the following
believe the japanese will fold up before
russia comes in
i am sure they will when manhattan
appears
over their homeland so here truman is
presenting the bombs as an event that
will preempt a russian invasion as the
thing that will cause
the japanese to fold up this was an
opinion
shared by james burns who later wrote in
his memoirs that
during the potsdam conference quote i
would have been satisfied had the
russians determined not to enter the war
notwithstanding japan's persistent
refusal to surrender i believed the
atomic bomb would be successful
and would force the japanese to accept
surrender on our terms
i feared what would happen when the red
army entered manchuria
james burns also rather candidly
admitted in a post-war interview that
quote
it was ever present in my mind that it
was important that we have an end to the
war before the russians came in
neither the president nor i were anxious
to have them enter the war
after we'd land of this successful test
so here burns is directly tying the
desire to keep the russians out of the
war
to the news coming in from the trinity
test and
walter brown who was assistant to james
burns at potsdam wrote in his diary on
the 24th of july
that burns told him he believed that
after the atomic bomb was dropped
japan will surrender and russia will not
get in so much
on the kill so the plan was to get
russia to invade manchuria something
that would likely finish the war
but finishing the war with russia's help
does mean having to deal with stalin
being at the negotiating table
afterwards
and given the difficulty of how the
european negotiations are going
and how roosevelt god rest his soul has
already gone and promised stalin a bunch
of concessions for helping out
maybe it wouldn't be such a bad thing if
russia ended up not being necessary here
after all
and since the trinity test was just a
big success we now have these very
destructive nuclear bombs to play with
and maybe when we use these japan might
surrender
to us specifically before russia even
declares war
and wouldn't that be handy and i'd like
to point out two more things about this
diary entry on july the 18th
the first is that truman writes he
believes the japanese will fold up
before russia comes in he does not write
i believe the japanese will fold up
before a u.s invasion of japan is
necessary
an invasion of japan is already off the
table here as far as truman is concerned
truman and burns are not presenting the
bombs as an alternative to a u.s
invasion of japan as a means to end the
war
they are presenting the bombs as an
alternative to a soviet
invasion of manchuria as a means to end
the war
the second thing i'd like to point out
about this diary entry is that truman
writes the japanese will fold up
when manhattan appears over their
homeland and that's when
not if truman writes about the use of
the nuclear bombs as a thing that simply
is going to happen and then he
speculates about the effects they will
have
nowhere here is the thought that the
bombs might possibly not need to be used
as truman later states in his memoirs i
regarded the bomb as a military weapon
and never had any doubt that it should
be used
and this is concerning in light of the
fact that on july 18th
truman learned of the message that the
canoe mission was to deliver to stalin
after meeting with churchill truman
notes in his diary that stalin had told
pm
that's prime minister churchill of
telegram from the japanese emperor
asking for peace stalin also read his
answer to me
it was satisfactory as for what stalin's
satisfactory answer was we can read this
account of admiral leahys
of a meeting 10 days later stalin
enlivened the proceedings by reporting
that on july 18th
he had received a request from japan to
mediate for them with the allies to end
the war
he said this request included a proposal
to send a royal prince of japan to
moscow
as chief of the mission the
generalissimo said that his reply was
that the proposal was too vague to
warrant his approving a meeting with the
proposed mission
stalin then says that he had that day
received another message from japan
attempting to clarify
the purpose of the mission but that he
was going to send the japanese the same
response
lee he concludes that it was clearly
evident that stalin was at that time
determined to enter the war against
japan which plainly was to the advantage
of russia now that japan was certain to
be defeated
so tokyo is sending messages to stalin
asking for him to mediate and enter the
war
and he's avoiding answering them
directly and instead repeatedly asking
for clarifications
and he's clearly just buying time while
he prepares for an invasion
more like joseph stalling anyway to get
back on track
president truman knows at potsdam that
the japanese leadership are
in his words asking for peace
so given that why we might wonder was
there no doubt in truman's mind about
the need to set off nuclear bombs in the
middle of civilian population centers
now we could simply say that truman had
resolved to drop the atomic bomb
on civilians in order to force a
japanese surrender on favorable terms
before the soviet union invaded
manchuria
however this interpretation of events
seemingly conflicts with another diary
entry that truman wrote on the 25th
of july when talking about the upcoming
bombings he says
this weapon is to be used against japan
between now and
august 10th i have told the secretary of
war mr stimson
to use it so that military objectives
and soldiers and sailors are the target
and not women and children he and i
are in accord the target will be a
purely military one
so what's going on here truman states in
this diary entry that the bomb is going
to be used against a purely
military target now by no stretch of the
imagination can the middle of a civilian
population
center be considered a purely military
target
it is in fact the exact place you would
drop the bomb if you were trying to
target women and children
if the middle of a city counts as a
purely military target
then there is nowhere the bomb could be
dropped that would not count as a purely
military target
making the question of whether to drop
it on a purely military target or not
completely pointless
and he's talking to henry stimson who of
course
knows the bomb is going to be dropped on
a city but has apparently tricked
himself into believing the lazy
euphemism about a war plant surrounded
by workers houses being a purely
military target
truman and stimpson are acting like the
bomb is going to be dropped on a
military base or an airfield or
something and then patting themselves on
the back
for not dropping it on civilians for
whatever reason
truman is thinking about the bomb as
though it is only going to affect enemy
soldiers
he seems to understand that it would be
wrong to drop the bomb on civilians
but not that that is exactly what is
about to happen
as for why this is there are three
possible explanations that i can imagine
the first is that truman genuinely
thinks the bomb is not going to be
dropped on civilians and that the target
list only includes military races or
something
in this version of events truman is told
by stimson that the bomb is going to be
dropped on a purely military target
believes him and is later surprised by
the fact the bombs have actually been
dropped on civilians
and so he orders that no more nuclear
bombs should be dropped without his
express permission which is something he
did do
after the second bomb was dropped by the
way then i guess he realizes that he's
massively screwed up but decides to just
run with it and pretend that was the
plan all along because that's easier at
that point than admitting the enormous
incompetence and being like
sorry i didn't actually mean to blow up
two cities that's
my bad the second explanation is that
truman is simply deluding himself
he knows exactly what the target is but
he's convincing himself it's something
else
if he really thought about it he'd know
that the bomb was not going to land on a
purely military target
so he's not thinking about it and he's
deceiving himself
the third explanation i can imagine is
that truman is just consciously lying
he knows the bomb is not going to be
dropped on a purely military target
but he's falsely claiming that that is
what he believes
at this point in time and i suppose this
could have been done with an eye on his
place in the history books or to protect
himself if there was any significant
repercussions after the bombs
then he could have pointed to this and
claimed hey i ordered them to be dropped
on military targets you can't pin this
on me
all these options are just speculation
on my part however
if i was forced to guess i'd say he was
probably deceiving himself but i do not
know the actual reason why truman wrote
that the bombs were only going to be
used on military targets
i only know that for whatever reason
when he wrote that
he was wrong now leaving the nuclear
bombs to the side for a moment
i wouldn't blame someone for asking at
this point if truman and burns are
apparently so anxious to get the war
over with before the russians get
involved
and they knew at potsdam that the
emperor was asking for peace
why was peace not able to be negotiated
sooner than it was
why when they heard the emperor wanted
peace did they not simply send him a
message saying
great okay let's negotiate peace and the
answer to that is the deadlock
over unconditional surrender as we know
japan was committed to avoiding an
unconditional surrender
but truman was likewise committed to
securing one he didn't want to accept
what the japanese were offering which
was a negotiated peace
he wanted a full unconditional surrender
now various individuals within the
allied governments and armed forces
understood that insisting on absolute
unconditional surrender was
particularly with regards to the
question of the emperor
going to cause problems and possibly
prolong the war
while at the altar conference winston
churchill suggested that mitigating the
terms of surrender quote
would be worthwhile if it led to the
saving of a year or a year and a half of
war
in which so much blood and treasure
would be poured out
but president roosevelt was unreceptive
to churchill's suggestion
not to be deterred however churchill
tried again when talking to truman at
potsdam
and he later gave an account of the
conversation i dwelt upon the tremendous
cost in american life and to a smaller
extent in british life which would be
involved in forcing
unconditional surrender upon the
japanese it was for him to consider
whether this might not be expressed in
some other way
so that we got all the essentials for
future peace and security
and yet left the japanese some show of
saving their military honor and some
assurance of their national existence
however churchill found this president
as unreceptive as the last
truman quote countered by saying that he
did not think the japanese had any
military honour after pearl harbor
but churchill responded that at any rate
they had something for which they were
ready to face certain death in very
large numbers
and this might not be so important to us
as to them
others attempted to influence truman on
the unconditional surrender issue at
various times
sometimes seemingly having more luck
than churchilla
under secretary of state joseph grew who
understood the importance of the emperor
having been u.s ambassador to japan for
a decade
advised truman on the 28th of may that
the greatest obstacle to unconditional
surrender by the japanese is their
belief that this would entail the
destruction or permanent removal of the
emperor and the institution of the
throne
and guru goes on to say that without an
assurance that the imperial institution
would not be destroyed a japanese
surrender would be highly
unlikely and he further notes that the
president said that he was interested in
what i said because his own thoughts had
been following the same line
another of truman's advisors who took a
similar line was secretary of war henry
stimpson
who spoke to truman on the 2nd of july
on the issue of drafting surrender terms
for japan stating that i
personally think that if we should add
that we do not exclude a constitutional
monarchy under her present dynasty
it would substantially add to the
chances of acceptance
and stimson later wrote in his diary
that truman was quote apparently
acquiescent with my attitude towards the
treatment of japan
now i think there's two possibilities
here the first is that president harry s
truman was one of those intensely
annoying people who simply agree with
whatever the last person they spoke to
said to them showing absolutely no
respect for future historians attempting
to figure out what they actually thought
about anything
the second is that truman was actually
sympathetic to what his advisors were
advising him with regards to softening
unconditional surrender
but there was some other influence
preventing him from acting on that
advice
and we perhaps see a hint of this at a
meeting on the 18th of june
when this time admiral leahy tried his
look at pushing for a softening of
unconditional surrender
stating that our insistence on
unconditional surrender would result
only in making the japanese desperate
and thereby increase
our casualty lists and truman responded
that
he did not feel that he could take any
action at this time to change
public opinion on the matter so the
opinion of the public
is being factored into the
decision-making process regarding
japanese surrender terms
and i think it's fair to say that the
united states public were not the
biggest fans of emperor hirohito
a gallup poll conducted on the 29th of
june reported that when asked what the
fate of the emperor should be after the
war the most popular response
was execute him so any u.s president
with an eye on public opinion
is in a bit of a tricky position when it
comes to openly telling japan they can
keep their emperor
especially if said u.s president has a
history of calling for unconditional
surrender
just about the only person not advising
truman to soften the surrender terms was
james burns who will later rather
dramatically state that truman appearing
to back down from unconditional
surrender would lead to the crucifixion
of the president all of this is
complicated by the fact that
behind the scenes the leadership of the
allied military did not desire to get
rid of the emperor
in fact there was actually a pressing
military reason to retain the emperor
and to quote a meeting of the combined
chiefs of staff that took place on the
16th of july
when discussing unconditional surrender
it was suggested that
if for instance an interpretation could
be found and communicated to the
japanese which did not
involve the dissolution of the imperial
institution the emperor would be in a
position to order the ceasefire in
outlying areas whereas if the dynasty
were destroyed
the outlying garrisons might continue to
fight for many months or years
so the proposal here is to leave the
emperor in place
and use his influence to convince the
scattered japanese troops to stand down
whereas if they simply kill or imprison
the emperor that might prompt the troops
to fight on
so truman's being pulled in different
directions here
strictly militarily speaking letting
japan keep the emperor makes a lot of
sense
it will almost certainly shorten the war
save lives and be the thing to convince
the japanese military to give up
conveying that message to the japanese
leadership
prior to their surrender though is
potentially risky from a domestic
political standpoint
if you've previously been calling for
unconditional surrender you don't want
to be seen as reversing position on that
and giving in to a hated enemy's demands
however the threat of the soviet union's
expansion into asia
means you do want to end the war quickly
so there's conflicting motivations
here and these conflicting motivations
came to influence the construction
of the potsdam declaration now this was
a statement issued by the allies on the
26th of july that called for the
unconditional surrender of japan
saying we call upon the government of
japan to proclaim now the unconditional
surrender of all japanese armed forces
and to provide proper and
adequate assurances of their good faith
in such
action the alternative for japan is
prompt and
utter destruction and it laid out
various terms
such as the occupation of japanese
territory by the allies
the disarming of the japanese military
and so on
notably however the potsdam declaration
did not contain
any mention of the emperor which you
might think is rather odd given that the
allies clearly know how important the
question of the imperial institution was
to the japanese leadership
however it did state that the authority
and influence of those who have deceived
and misled the people of japan into
embarking on world conquest
must be eliminated for all time and this
is rather vague with respect to exactly
who it means
does the emperor count as one of those
who have misled the people of japan
when the japanese leadership received
the potsdam declaration the hardliners
on the supreme council interpreted this
in a very unfavorable way and took it to
be an
indirect threat to the emperor's life
another
confusing point for the japanese
leadership was that when the potsdam
declaration was issued it was signed by
the united states
britain china and interestingly
not the soviet union to the supreme
council this
inspired a question as well as a fair
bit of false hope
if the soviet union didn't sign this
declaration
does that mean that they possibly
disagree with the declaration
what is russia's position here since
they didn't sign the document calling
for our unconditional surrender
does that mean they might be open to
negotiating better times for us after
all
after receiving the potsdam declaration
togo met with the emperor to discuss it
the emperor thought that the terms of
the declaration were quote
acceptable in principle but he agreed to
postpone a response until after they had
heard back from the soviet union
so togo sent a message to ambassador
sato on the 28th
of july with instructions to attempt to
sound out the russian attitude
towards the joint declaration ambassador
sato for his part
had had just about enough of this
nonsense
he had been repeatedly saying that the
russia plan was not going to work
and yet here's another message from
tokyo postponing surrender in order to
ask what the situation is with the
russians
sato's messages in response were openly
insubordinate and strayed into
brazenly telling tokyo what to do sato
said
and i'm paraphrasing here look if stalin
disagreed with the terms of the potsdam
declaration he would have negotiated
better terms at the time
and if he wasn't able to negotiate
better times at the time
he's not going to be able to do that now
is he the soviet union
is not going to help you in fact if you
don't immediately surrender they are
probably going to declare war on you
the supreme council on receiving these
messages
finally saw sense and decided to end the
war
no i'm joking sato was ignored obviously
so the potsdam declaration contained no
direct information about the fate of the
emperor and it left open the question of
the soviet union's position which
prompted the japanese leadership to
postpone a response until they knew what
that was
until then their official position was
to ignore the declaration
so if the potsdam declaration was
intended to produce a surrender from
japan
it failed however when the potsdam
declaration was first drafted
by the office of secretary of war henry
stimson
it included the following point the
occupying forces of the allies shall be
withdrawn from japan as soon as our
objectives are accomplished and there
has been established beyond doubt a
peacefully inclined
responsible government of a character
representative
of the japanese people this may include
a constitutional monarchy
under the present dynasty so that is a
concrete offer to retain the imperial
institution right there
and earlier drafts of the potsdam
declaration
also included among the signatories the
generalissimo
of the soviet union so what
happened here then well between the
first draft leaving stimson's office and
it being
issued publicly the potsdam declaration
went through various drafts
most importantly for us here the
document was edited by president truman
and
james burns the final draft of course
saw the soviet union being removed from
the list of signatories and the offer to
retain the imperial institution
deleted firstly on the issue of the
soviet union being removed from the
declaration
president truman simply writes in his
memoirs that stalin could not
of course be a party to the proclamation
itself since he was still at peace with
japan
so that's truman's stated reason for
excluding the soviet union from the
declaration the soviet union is not yet
in the war and technically still has a
non-aggression pact in place with japan
but why we might ask does this mean that
the soviet union can't sign a document
calling for japan to surrender i mean
truman's
stated intent for going to potsdam was
to convince the russians to violate that
non-aggression pact and have their
military attack the japanese military
so i'm going to go ahead and assume that
respect for the sanctity of
non-aggression pacts is clearly not the
reason here
and if truman is implying that he was
worried that the soviet union signing
the document would lead to war between
russia and japan
well that's what he's supposed to want
to happen
in fact the soviet union's exclusion
from the final draft of the document
came as an enormous surprise to the
delegation from the soviet union who had
written their own draft of the potsdam
declaration which included
themselves as signatories so they
clearly wanted in
on the signing of the document instead
the soviet delegation was not consulted
about the drafting of the declaration
and were only told it was being released
to the press
at the same time it was being released
soviet minister of foreign affairs
molotov submitted a request
to delay the publication of the
declaration but james burns
claimed he didn't get the message in
time hmm
as for why the soviet union wanted to be
included among the list of signatories
stalin and molotov wanted a pretext to
abandon their non-aggression pact with
japan
and invade manchuria and the potsdam
declaration's ultimatum to japan would
have provided that pretext
so after being edited out of the
declaration they tried a more direct
approach
in a meeting on the 29th of july molotov
submitted a request from stalin for the
united states
england and the other allies quote to
address a formal request
to the soviet government for its entry
into the war
now this put truman and burns in a very
awkward position
because of course they're supposed to
want the soviet government to enter the
war
but they clearly don't anymore as burns
later wrote in its memoirs
we had of course begun to hope a
japanese surrender might be imminent and
we did not want to urge the russians to
enter the war
truman and burns figure they just have
to wait a week or so for the first
nuclear bomb to be dropped
and then japan will surrender before the
soviet union has a chance to declare
war and invade so being asked directly
for an invitation to the war put truman
on the spot
and he sidestepped the issue the soviets
would get no
invitation from him however an
interesting note here is that when the
soviet union does actually declare war
on japan they say they have acceded
to the allied request to join the war so
they didn't get an invitation
but they just acted like they did anyway
now of course
excluding the soviets from the potsdam
declaration and dodging their request
for an invitation to join the war
confirmed to stalin that truman was
planning to finish the war without him
so while at potsdam stalin ordered his
generals to speed up their invasion
plans
he wasn't going to be left out of the
kill
so i think it's fairly clear why the
soviet union was excluded from the
potsdam declaration
burns and truman are planning to finish
the war without stalin and that includes
not having
stalin's signature on the surrender
papers so when japan surrenders it will
not be
in any way a surrender to the soviet
union
is the plan the second important edit to
the potsdam declaration was the removal
of the offer to retain the imperial
institution
and the reasoning for this change is
found in the diary of henry stimson
who writes that when the potsdam
conditions were drawn and left my office
where they originated
they contained a provision which
permitted the continuance of the dynasty
with certain conditions
the president and burns struck that out
they were not obdurate on it but they
thought they could arrange it in the
necessary secret negotiations which
would take place
after any armistice so truman and burns
think the position of the emperor is a
matter to be negotiated
after japan has already surrendered and
they're both convinced that the nuclear
bomb is definitely about to force an
unconditional surrender from japan
remember that truman is quote sure that
japan will surrender
when manhattan appears over their
homeland so given that
why should they make any concessions
beforehand and risk an unnecessary
backlash
truman and burns plan to use the bomb to
make japan surrender unconditionally
before russia joins the war and
anything else like the position of the
emperor can simply be sorted out
afterwards so here's the situation we're
in at the end of the potsdam conference
the japanese leadership is still
refusing to accept an unconditional
surrender
but truman is refusing to accept
anything less even though on the
principal point
the fate of the emperor both sides are
in agreement they don't want to get rid
of the emperor
but since neither side wanted to blink
first the deadlock remained
japan waited for rescue from the soviet
union that would never come
and the united states moved forward with
the atomic bombings
the first atomic bomb was dropped in the
center of hiroshima on august 6th at
about 8 15 in the morning
it exploded directly above a hospital
immediately killing everyone inside
within the immediate blast radius with
the hong kong and fukuromachi
elementary schools which were completely
destroyed instantly incinerating
hundreds of school children
this is the purely military target right
here
now my video is about the reasons why
these bombs were dropped not the actual
explosions themselves
there are many sources for first-hand
accounts of the terrifying effects of
the atomic bomb
and you can look those up yourself if
you're in a particularly good mood today
and would like to ruin it
i'll just say here that tens of
thousands of civilians including
thousands of schoolchildren were killed
permanently injured and disfigured in a
number of cruel and horrible ways
many of those not killed by the initial
blast also suffered the effects of
radiation poisoning which killed and
made seriously sick many more people
all together between the two atomic
bombs it's estimated that between 129
and 226 000 people were killed
and the vast majority of these were
innocent civilians
this is particularly true in the case of
nagasaki where it is estimated that of
the tens of thousands of people who were
killed
only 150 of them were soldiers when the
leadership of japan got news of the
hiroshima bomb
they discussed what to do foreign
minister togo saw in the bomb a chance
to end the war
and he argued at a meeting on the 7th of
august that japan should now accept the
terms of the potsdam declaration
he was ignored the militarists on the
council were too far
gone at this point to be shaken by the
destruction of just one more city
war minister anami after hearing the
news said i am convinced that the
americans had only one bomb
after all even after the destruction of
hiroshima anami and the other
militarists remained committed to
pursuing
a negotiated peace togo met with the
emperor the next day
on august 8th and they both agreed that
the war was lost and they should
surrender
but even these two who have both wanted
peace for a long time now are still
thinking at this point about the
possibility
of negotiating a peace togo stated after
the war that while he
and the emperor wanted to end the war
quote as soon as possible
they would not completely discard the
possibility of negotiating conditions
armed with the emperor's wish that the
war should be ended
togo called a meeting of the supreme
council for the direction of the war to
be held
the next day as some ministers were
unavailable
and i'd like to comment on two
incredibly frustrating things here
first is obviously that the japanese
leadership did not unanimously and
immediately unconditionally surrender
the militarists were still conning
themselves into thinking they would get
to force favorable terms by fighting
against an allied invasion
the second incredibly frustrating thing
is just how amazingly slowly this
process is going
hiroshima was bombed on august 6th
togo's advice to surrender was ignored
on august 7th
he met with the emperor to discuss what
to do on august 8th
and then called the supreme council
meeting to discuss things further
on august 9th because some ministers
weren't
available sooner what were they doing
oh they had something more important to
do clearly
where were they if truman and burns had
intended the bomb to immediately shock
the japanese leadership out of the war
they severely miscalculated the
militarists heard of the destruction of
hiroshima
and they shrugged it was just one more
bombed city
they'd seen dozens of those already the
emperor
and the less unwise members of the
council desired peace
as they had before but despite claims
they wanted to end the war as quickly as
possible
they too were moving in slow motion
there is an arrogant
lack of urgency here the emperor
isn't ordering an end to the war here
he's simply letting it be known
again that he thinks ending the war is
desirable
and asking togo to pass the message on
to the supreme council once they get
back off their holidays or wherever
it was they went more than a full day
after the atomic bomb was dropped on
hiroshima
ambassador sato in moscow received the
following message from tokyo
the situation is becoming more and more
pressing and we would like to know at
once the explicit attitude of the
russians
so will you put forth still greater
efforts to get a reply from them in
haste
upon reading this i picture sato
justifiably imagining himself doing
various types of violence to the members
of the supreme council
sarto wouldn't have to wait long to find
out as though he needed to
the explicit attitude of the russians
molotov summoned sato to the kremlin on
august 8
and handed him the soviet union's
declaration of war against
japan and you rarely have to feel for
the poor bastard at this point
he warned them this was coming and they
didn't listen
the soviet army crossed the border into
japanese occupied manchuria near
midnight on the 8th of august
and began smashing apart the japanese
defenses because their leadership had
refused to accept the inevitable reality
of an
imminent russian invasion the
under-equipped japanese troops were not
prepared for or
expecting a fight and they were quickly
overwhelmed
when the news of the soviet declaration
of war reached tokyo
prime minister suzuki met with cabinet
secretary sakomizu
and after discussing the news came to
the conclusion that their only two
options were either
to declare war on the soviet union and
fight to certain death
or they could accept the terms of the
potsdam declaration
suzuki met with the emperor early in the
morning on the 9th of august and the
emperor agreed to accept the terms
of the potsdam declaration a meeting of
the supreme council
was called the six members of the
council met to discuss their upcoming
surrender and
immediately deadlocked again i sound
like a broken record here
i know but the moderate faction
supported accepting the potsdam
declaration with the singular condition
that the imperial institution be
protected
and the militarist faction supported
accepting it only if they got to keep
the emperor
do their own war crimes trials remain
free of foreign occupation
everyone gets a pony the army gets
fridays off now
etc hours into this ridiculous
conversation
a messenger arrived to announce that
nagasaki had just been hit with a
nuclear
bomb now if anyone expects this news to
have
any impact whatsoever upon the impasse
in the supreme council
i have done a very poor job of
explaining what the supreme council is
like
the bombing of nagasaki of course had no
effect
whatsoever the council remained
deadlocked
they spoke for hours they upgraded to a
full government cabinet meeting with 16
members
they spoke for hours again in that
meeting no conclusion was reached and
they broke for dinner
now i wouldn't blame anyone for
considering this a very unlikely
sequence of events
how could they be hit with two nuclear
bombs and that still not be enough to
break this deadlock
and the answer to that is they the
supreme council
haven't been hit with any nuclear bombs
some unimportant peasants somewhere have
been hit with nuclear bombs
the council are fine they don't care
this brings us back to one of the
failures of morale bombing
totalitarian militaristic regimes don't
give a toss about their citizens
you can't frighten them by killing poor
people
that's their day job at one or other of
these council meetings prior to the end
of the war
chief of the army general staff umezu
was asked about japan's defense against
atomic bombs
and he replied though we haven't made
sufficient progress so far in dealing
with air raids
no kidding we should expect better
results soon since we have revised our
tactics
but there is no reason to surrender to
our enemies
as a result of air raids so that's the
militarist position on the bombs stated
pretty clearly there
they don't really care the nuclear bombs
were no reason to surrender
this impasse in the council did need to
be broken somehow
though so suzuki togo and sakomizu met
in the prime minister's office
and hatched a plan to have the emperor
himself resolve the argument with a
sacred
royal judgment something which was
highly unusual
the emperor was not supposed to get
involved in affairs of state
so directly to achieve this they had to
call an imperial conference
so suzuki went to the emperor to request
that one be called a request which was
granted
immediately which is very shocking for
this lot i'm surprised they didn't take
a week off to think about it
at this imperial conference the members
of the supreme council
immediately deadlocked along the same
lines as all the previous meetings
their arguments were the same as before
the militarists wanted to insist on
attaching multiple conditions to their
offer to accept the potsdam declaration
and the moderates wanted to attach only
one
the preservation of the emperor they
talked until past two am in the morning
when prime minister suzuki talking over
the protests of war minister anami
dared to ask the emperor directly what
he wanted to do
the emperor said he agreed with the
moderates and this intervention did the
trick
japan would offer to accept the terms of
the potsdam declaration quote
with the understanding that said
declaration does not comprise any demand
which prejudices the prerogatives of his
majesty
as a sovereign ruler truman and his
advisors got the message that morning
on the 10th of august and they gathered
to discuss their response
admiral leahy thought that the condition
should be accepted
he argued that the matter of the
emperor's position was a trivial one
compared to passing up an opportunity to
bring an
end to the war secretary stimson
likewise thought the condition should be
accepted
and he also notes in his diary in my
opinion with a slightly sarcastic tone
it is curious that this was the very
single point that i feared would make
trouble and then he talks about his
earlier draft of the potsdam declaration
which included an offer to retain the
imperial institution
the very thing that was now delaying the
end of the war
if stimson managed not to say i told you
so then he's a more disciplined man than
i
in support of accepting the japanese
condition stimson argued that the united
states wanted to keep the emperor
anyway they needed to use his power to
convince the japanese military to stand
down
stimson was also aware that time was a
factor here
the soviet army was on the march and he
thought that the war with japan needed
to be ended quickly
before the russians were able to reach
the japanese homeland
james burns on the other hand said no
we should not accept this condition i do
not see why we should
retreat from our demand for
unconditional surrender he said
if any conditions are to be accepted i
want the united states
and not japan to state the conditions
that was his account of his words
from his memoirs there so the conditions
to the unconditional surrender work that
out should be coming from
us here they lost the war why do they
get to say the conditions
we won we say the conditions a
justification for burns position is
found in stimson's diary where he writes
that
burns was troubled and anxious to find
out whether we could accept this in
light of some of the public statements
by roosevelt and truman
of course during three years of a bitter
war there have been bitter statements
made about the emperor
now they come to plague us so according
to stimson
burns is again worried here about the
public perception of backing away from
unconditional surrender we've been
calling the emperor
a monstrous dictator for the last three
years and
now we're gonna let him off the hook
because he told us to
that's not gonna play so truman and his
advisors came up with a compromise
position
they would send a note to japan written
by burns
intending to imply without stating it so
directly
that japan would be allowed to keep the
emperor the note stated that
the emperor shall issue his commands to
all the japanese military naval and
air authorities and to all the forces
under their control were ever located
to cease active operations and to
surrender their
arms and to issue such other orders as
the supreme commander may require
to give effect to the surrender terms so
they're giving the emperor a list of
jobs basically they're implying that he
gets to stay around by laying out what
his role is going to be going forward
and the note also states that the
ultimate form of government of japan
shall
in accordance with the potsdam
declaration be established by the freely
expressed will
of the japanese people truman sums up
the intended aim of the burns note in
his diary when he says
they wanted to make a condition
precedent to the surrender
they wanted to keep the emperor we told
him we'd tell him how to keep him
but we'd make the terms so what's
happened here is the united states said
to japan
we demand you surrender unconditionally
and japan responded we will gladly
accept unconditional surrender
on the condition that you first agree to
this condition to that unconditional
surrender
to which the united states responded oh
we will happily agree to this condition
to the unconditional surrender
on the condition that you agree that
you're accepting the condition
not that we are accepting the condition
you're keeping the emperor because we
want that
not because you want that so there when
the japanese leadership received the
burns note
well we all know how this goes by now
don't we
there was yet another stalemate they
disagreed over its exact meaning
there were arguments plots threats
proposed possible revisions to the note
prime minister suzuki swapped sides for
a bit and then
swapped back again none of this matters
at all they're just wasting time
not accomplishing anything after several
days of this nonsense the
emperor intervened to break the
stalemate
again on august 14th the emperor
summoned his cabinet to an imperial
conference
listened once more to the tedious
arguments of the militarists and
responded that he had not changed his
mind
and still wanted to end the war this
second
direct intervention finally mercifully
brought about a surrender
japan would accept the terms of the
potsdam declaration
at 12 midday on august 15th the emperor
broadcast by public radio an address
announcing
that the war was over now around this
time there was a coup attempt organized
by some junior officers in the japanese
military
trying to prevent japan's surrender but
they failed to gain support of the
military leadership
and it quickly fizzled out war minister
anami refused to support the coup
choosing instead to go home and commit
suicide
and though the war with the other allies
was over stalin stepped up his offensive
against the japanese occupied
territories he wished
to capture surrender or no surrender
stalin was going to take what he felt he
was
owed and russia's annexing for instance
of several of the kuril islands led to a
dispute over ownership that is still
going on today
with both japan and russia arguing over
who has
sovereignty of the islands when really
it should be neither of them
there were already people on those
islands before either russia or japan
turned up
other than that though the second world
war was over
just about now with regards to our main
topic today we can ask a question
what effect did the nuclear bombs have
on japan's decision to end the war
well japan needed three main things i
would argue
in order to end the war firstly they had
to be in a hopeless military situation
with no chance of winning the war
and be aware of that and this one we can
tick off the japanese leadership
knew it had no chance to actually defeat
the allies militarily
they had known that for quite a while
their only hope for their military was
to use whatever was left of it to drag
out the war with the hopes of securing
better peace terms for themselves
secondly japan had to be in a hopeless
diplomatic situation
and be aware of that now ever since the
russians signed the secret pact to
declare war on japan
at the yalta conference the japanese
government was in a hopeless diplomatic
situation
but for a long time they didn't
understand that they were
they held out hope for russian mediation
all the way until the soviet union
declared war on them
now some of the actions of the allies
undoubtedly contributed to japan not
understanding the position they were in
principle among those probably being the
soviet union's signature being struck
off the potsdam declaration
but we also can't ignore the capacity
for willful ignorance
and self-deception among the members of
the japanese leadership
they should have known their situation
was hopeless
after the soviet union declared war on
japan however
the japanese leadership finally
understood this second point
and i'd like to add something here the
strategic bombing survey that i
mentioned at the start of the video
stated
japan would have surrendered even if the
atomic bombs had not been dropped
even if russia had not entered the war
and even if no invasion had been planned
or contemplated
now i don't actually agree with that on
the russia point
anyway i personally feel that if the
japanese leadership with regards to
getting help from the soviet union
thought there was any hope remaining
whatsoever they probably
never would have surrendered even if it
meant their entire country was banned to
the ground
the soviet union declaring war on japan
was crucial
in that it forced them to confront their
hopeless diplomatic situation
to return to our list of things japan
needed in order to end the war
third is an assurance that the imperial
institution would not be abolished
this was the main problem the japanese
leadership had with the ally to demand
for
unconditional surrender of course and
i'd argue that the question of the
emperor
was the most important point on this
list and that's both on a national level
the emperor being a very important
figure in japanese society
but also on a personal level because
it's the emperor himself
intervening to end the war so an
assurance that the emperor himself would
not be executed as a result of doing
that
would probably help to speed things
along there people who defend
the atomic bombings as being necessary
often point to the bluster of the
japanese militarists who were
even after the bombings and the russian
declaration of war
still promising to fight to the last
with the desperate idea of somehow
securing better terms for themselves
but they didn't do that once the emperor
intervened
and the emperor intervened not to avoid
more cities being destroyed remember
dozens of cities had already been
destroyed the emperor intervened to
protect the imperial
office in a post-war interview he
explained one of his reasons for
choosing to intervene
as being that quote if the enemy landed
near ise bay both issei and atsuta
shrines would immediately come under
their control
there would be no time to transfer the
sacred regalia of the imperial family
and no hope of protecting them
now you'd think that protecting the
imperial knickknacks would be an
unmentionably minor concern when
compared to the nuclear bombing grades
but apparently not
the emperor took all this emperor
business very seriously
as did the rest of the japanese
government the militarists on the
supreme council might have wanted to
hold out for better terms even if it
meant
fighting to the death but they were not
prepared to contradict
the will of the emperor admiral leahy
wrote in his memoirs that himself
and secretary stimson in their combined
staff meetings were quote
certain that the mikado that's an
antiquated term for the emperor
could stop the war with a royal word and
this turned out to be accurate
that is how the war was stopped on the
japanese end
now i don't want to get too deep into
speculation about
alternate history timelines today but i
think it's
fairly obvious that president truman and
james burns deleting the offer to retain
the imperial institution from the
potsdam declaration
almost certainly lengthened the war if
the emperor didn't intervene to bring
about a surrender
immediately upon receiving peace terms
that assured his position
he almost certainly would have when that
was coupled with a soviet declaration of
war
japan had only been holding out for
russian mediation in the hopes of
securing better peace
terms after the soviet declaration of
war that
option was fully off the table so i'd
say it's vastly more likely than not
that having in hand both a declaration
of war from the soviet union
and surrender terms from the other
allies that assured the imperial house
would survive
the emperor would have ended the war
right there regardless of whether japan
had been hit with nuclear bombs or not
henry stimpson later noted in his
memoirs that it is possible
in light of the final surrender that a
clearer and
earlier exposition of american
willingness to retain the emperor would
have produced an
earlier ending to the war and he
concluded
in 1948 that history might find that the
united states
by its delay in stating its position had
prolonged the war
now it would be very simple to conclude
at this point that
with regards to the end of the war the
question of the emperor
was everything and the nuclear bombs
didn't do anything
but is that really the case let's pose a
few questions
firstly we can ask were the bombs
necessary to defeat japan
militarily and the answer to that is
obviously
no the japanese leadership were beaten
and they knew they were beaten
long before the bombs were dropped so
were the bombs necessary to defeat japan
without needing to carry out a ground
invasion of the four main japanese
islands
well to start with we've quoted multiple
us military leaders today who say that
japan
was ready to surrender without either an
invasion or the bombs being necessary
but can we really trust their judgment
of the situation
you see those leaders had a couple of
potential reasons to downplay the
effectiveness
of the bomb the first of these is simply
that they didn't want to be put out of a
job
by this thing the worry there was that
if the atomic bombs really are that
effective then maybe we don't need
such a large conventional military force
anymore so
clear your desk and another reason i
imagine
was pride if it's you who's been
fighting the war all this time
backing japan into a corner and bringing
them to the verge of surrender
you probably don't want the narrative
afterwards to be scientists
save the day and end the war with their
new bomb
it kind of undercuts all the work you
did prior to that
so i can see the motive there for us
military leaders at the time to say hey
hang on japan was already beaten we did
that
the bomb was not necessary however these
ulterior motives do not mean that the
military leaders who spoke out against
the bomb were
necessarily lying or wrong we know from
what we've talked about today that the
japanese leadership
was close to surrender and was as
president truman wrote in his diary
asking for peace japan would have
surrendered long before an invasion if
for instance they thought they could
secure terms which were acceptable to
them
they didn't actually want to be invaded
just for the sake of it they were
holding out
for an invasion in the hopes of avoiding
an unconditional surrender
so us military leaders who claimed the
bombs were not necessary to end the war
were correct
even if they had an ulterior motive for
saying so
instead of a motivation to lie they
could just of easily have had a
motivation to tell
an uncomfortable truth so then were the
bombs necessary to force japan to offer
to surrender on the allied terms without
any conditions and the answer to this is
also
no because they didn't do that even
after two atomic bombs the japanese
leadership
still only offered to surrender on the
condition that they were assured
they could keep the emperor and between
that offered to surrender
and their eventual actual surrender they
didn't get hit with any more nuclear
bombs
all this being said i do not think that
the nuclear bombs had
absolutely no effect at all on japan's
decision to surrender
it would be going much too far to make
that claim in my opinion
i'd say there were two main effects that
the bombs had
upon the end of the war firstly the
nuclear bomb probably
indirectly shortened the war because its
existence prompted truman to try to
finish the war without the soviet union
which in turn prompted stalin to speed
up his plans to declare war on japan
and that declaration of war sped up the
emperor intervening in the supreme
council
to bring about an offer to surrender
with their condition of course
the soviet union declared war on japan
on the 8th
of august and it's likely that if they
weren't racing to get in the war as
quickly as possible
they would have declared war later in
august sometime the
15th is what stalin told truman at
potsdam
so we can say that all other things
being equal
the existence of the atomic bomb
probably shortened the war
by a week or so the other effect the
nuclear bomb had on the end of the war
is a rather interesting one
and let's read a post-war quote from
cabinet secretary sako mizu
talking about the bomb the chants had
come to end
the war it was not necessary to blame
the military side the manufacturing
people
or anyone else just the atomic bomb
it was a good excuse someone said the
atomic bomb
was the kamikaze to save japan so
the bomb provided the non-military
japanese leadership with an excuse to
proclaim defeat that didn't involve
blaming
or shaming their proud military it
lessened the risk of a revolt of the
armed forces and it was a way to end the
war while salvaging some pride
as well as casting those killed by the
bombs not as
civilian war victims but as heroic
martyrs the emperor's radio announcement
declaring the end of the war took a
similar approach
moreover the enemy has begun to employ a
new
and most cruel bomb the power of which
to do damage
is indeed incalculable taking the toll
of many
innocent lives should we continue to
fight it would not only result in an
ultimate collapse
and obliteration of the japanese nation
but also it would lead to the total
extinction
of human civilization so the bomb
allowed the japanese leadership to say
hey we weren't beaten in a fair fight
here
our brave military was gearing up for a
decisive last battle
but those cowardly americans they were
too scared to face us
so they invented this terrible bomb and
started dropping it on
innocent civilians those monsters so i
suppose we have to be the adults in the
room here and agree to stand down before
you lunatics go and blow up the whole
planet in a nuclear war
so instead of being beaten fairly here
we're sort of like
heroes for giving up right
does anyone buy that now this is
desperate spin from a government
trying to salvage whatever pride it
could anyone who takes this at face
value
particularly the bit about the toll of
many innocent
lives is falling for imperial propaganda
the emperor and the japanese leadership
did not care about the innocent civilian
casualties
the supreme council's plan for their
civilians was for them to die
in a wave of suicide attacks fighting a
vastly better equipped allied military
so do not lie to me that they suddenly
came over all sympathetic about their
poor subjects
the problem for the japanese leadership
was not that innocent civilians were
being killed it's that innocent
civilians were being killed
in a manner that was not useful they
didn't want them being blown up in
nuclear explosions
they wanted them rushing american
machine guns armed with bamboo sticks
if they actually gave a toss about their
civilians they would have surrendered
months before they did when it was
obvious the war was lost
instead they selfishly hung on trying to
save their own positions and reputations
they didn't want to take responsibility
for the enormous mistake they had made
so the bomb provided to the japanese
government an excuse to end the war that
did not involve
blaming anyone in particular it's not
anyone's fault all this it's not like we
did anything
wrong it's just that they've got nuclear
bombs now
and there's no accounting for that so
it's possible in this regard that the
bombs also shortened the war by
providing a
face saving excuse for the japanese
leadership to call it quits
now as for whether this was a decisive
factor as in if the bombs didn't exist
and the japanese government had no
similar excuse they wouldn't have
surrendered when they did
i honestly can't say however i will note
that both of these possible effects of
the bombs
those being speeding up the soviet
declaration of war
and providing a face-saving excuse to
quit
do not require the bombs to be dropped
in the middle of cities
and this is a very important point that
often goes overlooked
in the debate about whether the bombs
were necessary or not
because beyond whether the bombs were
necessary we also need to ask whether or
not it was necessary to use the bombs
in the manner in which they were used
there are other ways to use nuclear
bombs than to drop them on civilians of
course
on that note this person is leo zillard
zillard was a hungarian physicist who in
conceived the idea of a nuclear chain
reaction
zillard once lived in germany but he
left when hitler became the chancellor
in 1939 zillard approached albert
einstein and asked him to put his name
to a letter zillard had written
warning then-president roosevelt about
the possibility of
nazi development of nuclear weapons the
einstein zillad letter prompted action
by roosevelt
leading to the creation of the manhattan
project
which zillard also worked on now zillard
and many other scientists working on the
project were motivated by fears of a
nuclear nazi germany something which
thankfully never came about once it was
clear the nazis would be defeated
however
several scientists began warning against
the now
unnecessary use of the nuclear bomb a
document called the frank report was put
together in 1945 and signed by several
prominent physicists
including zillard the frank report
warned about the possibility of the
bomb's use triggering an
international arms race and strongly
advised against an unannounced attack
against japan
the scientists behind the frank report
instead advised truman that quote
a demonstration of the new weapon may
best be made before the eyes of
representatives of all united nations
on the desert or a barren island now
allow me to lay my cards on the table
here and say that this is how i think
things should have been handled
a public announcement and demonstration
of the bomb
coupled with an explicit warning to
japan would have provided the peace
faction in the japanese government with
the exact same excuse to quit
without blaming their military the
emperor could still have done his where
pulling out of the war to save the world
routine
except without two cities full of
civilians being destroyed
if the nuclear bombs were influential in
ending the war
it was by their existence not by their
use
in order to use them as an excuse to
surrender the japanese leadership just
needed to know about them
not actually be hit by them one argument
against
demonstrating the bomb publicly was that
they were worried it might not work
henry stimpson later wrote that nothing
would have been more damaging to our
effort to obtain surrender than a
warning or a demonstration
followed by a dud which is a perfectly
valid line of reasoning
until the trinity test when you know
they work
after that there's no excuse and the
infuriating thing about this is that if
this public demonstration and warning
didn't work
you could still then use them against
japan afterwards
i mean you shouldn't drop them on cities
regardless but you could do that
doing it this way around costs you
nothing and potentially spares the lives
of two cities full of civilians
the united states absolutely should have
went public with the bomb
however with regards to the frank
report's suggestions
groves and oppenheimer didn't appreciate
this bunch of bleeding hearts telling
them what to do with their new
toy oppenheimer had previously written
about the quote
fallacy of regarding a controlled test
as the culmination of the work of this
laboratory
the laboratory is operating under a
directive to produce
weapons this directive has been and will
be
rigorously adhered to so they didn't put
in all this time and effort just to blow
up an empty field somewhere for some
diplomats and journalists
they were making a weapon and they were
going to drop it on a city
without warning the frank report was
ignored
not to be deterred leo zillard put
together a petition
signed by 70 manhattan project
scientists warning truman about the
possibility of quote
opening the door to an era of
devastation on an unimaginable scale
in attempting to get this petition to
the president zillard
on the 28th of may met with james burns
who i'm sure you can guess was not very
sympathetic
to zillard's view zillard later stated
burns was concerned about russia's
post-war behavior
russian forces had moved into hungary
and romania burns thought it would be
very difficult to persuade russia to
withdraw its troops from these countries
and that russia would be more manageable
if impressed by american military might
i shared burns concern about russia's
throwing its weight around in the
post-war period but i was completely
flabbergasted by the assumption that
rattling the bomb might make russia more
manageable
zillard's petition never did make it to
truman
now this quote from burns here about
making the russians more manageable
along with other documents that came to
light in the post-war period for
instance the target committee's desire
for the bomb to be used in a manner that
would ensure
international recognition and truman's
diary entries revealing that he knew of
the emperor's desire for peace prior to
the bombs being used
allowed certain people to construct an
alternative historical narrative to the
accepted story of america using the bomb
to avoid an invasion of japan
in this new telling america thinking
ahead to the post-war period
used the bomb primarily as an indirect
diplomatic weapon against the soviet
union
rather than as a direct military weapon
against the empire of japan
now there is evidence to support that
this motivation was certainly a factor
it definitely was for secretary of state
james burns for instance
but this evidence has led some to
conclude that the bombs were dropped
solely to
intimidate russia and this is going much
too far in my opinion
anyone who points to a singular reason
as the explanation for why the bombs
were dropped is definitely
oversimplifying the history the bombs
were dropped for a combination
of many reasons and let's list some of
them
so first the bombs were dropped in part
to limit soviet influence in
asia and make other diplomatic
negotiations with the soviet union
ghost mover for the united states
although this turned out to be an
enormous miscalculation
it was assumed incorrectly that it would
take the soviets a lot longer to develop
their own nuclear weapons than it
actually did
and the united states would get to enjoy
a long stretch of time as the world's
only nuclear power
unbeknownst to truman however stalin had
spies inside the manhattan project who
were sending plans
and information back to russia in just a
few short years the soviet
union would be testing their own nuclear
weapons and the feared arms race
was on next the bombs were dropped in
part
to force an end to the war without the
united states being seen to back down
from unconditional surrender it was more
preferable
to certain people that the united states
set off nuclear bombs in the middle of
cities
than the president take a knock to his
popularity by looking hypocritical or
weak
another possible reason the bombs were
dropped was to justify their expense
admiral leahy argues in his memoirs that
it was my reaction that the scientists
and others wanted to make this test
because of the vast sums that had been
spent on the project
truman knew that and so did other people
involved
the manhattan project was enormously
expensive and diverted many of the
united states top scientists and
engineers away from other useful work
it was very costly in terms of dollars
materials
and manpower and the project's
management wanted something to show for
the expense
they didn't want the culmination of
their work to simply be blowing up a
field
somewhere another motivation surely was
revenge the white house press release
announcing the use of the bomb at
hiroshima stated
the japanese began the war from the air
at pearl harbor
they have been repaid many fold so this
thinking is that
the japanese began the war with a sneak
attack
they carried out many war crimes and
atrocities
they mistreated prisoners of war and
even though they began the war and
lost it they still arrogantly refused to
surrender and dared to try and impose
their own surrender times on the allied
forces that had beaten them
so yeah we bombed them but they were
asking for it
this motivation would be a lot more
sympathetic and understandable had the
bombs not been dropped on civilians
because counter to what the white house
press release said
the japanese did not begin the war at
pearl harbor the japanese leadership and
military did that the japanese civilians
were not consulted
if the united states wanted to use the
bombs to pay back pearl harbor they
should have dropped one on a military
target
or the supreme council i suppose related
to that last point
another motivation that influenced the
use of the bombs was just basic regular
racism
it is very worth remembering that the
racist ideas that inspired
nazi germany to commit such terrible
atrocities were not limited to that
country's borders
when we've been talking about america
today it was in america decades prior to
the signing of the civil rights act
james burns a very influential figure in
the events we've been talking about was
a supporter of racial segregation
and president truman himself referred to
the japanese people as
beasts several times and once when
defending the use of the bomb
specifically
he wrote that when you have to deal with
a beast you have to treat him
as a beast this is also undoubtedly one
of the reasons that japan and
not nazi germany was targeted with the
nuclear bombs
it was much easier for the people behind
the bomb to justify the use of such a
destructive weapon if it wasn't going to
be used to kill
white people and now hold up a second
scroll back up everyone who just
scrolled down to type in the comment box
that
of course the bombs were used against
japan and not nazi germany
nazi germany surrendered before the
bombs were ready to be used
now i know that obviously but i didn't
say used
i said targeted and japan was chosen as
the target for the nuclear bombs two
years before nazi germany's surrender
japan was chosen as the target way back
in 1943
and when general leslie groves briefed
president truman about the project in
april 1945
he stated the target is and was always
expected to be
japan another factor behind the use of
the bombs was simply the momentum of the
project
at the top of the united states
leadership there was a vacuum of
responsibility
with roosevelt's death and the newly
installed president truman only just
learning about the project
near to its completion there's a sense
that things were simply too far
along to be halted without very firm
leadership anyway
truman's job was not to get in the
bomb's way
leslie groves described truman's role in
the atomic bombings as quote
one of non-interference basically a
decision not to upset the existing plans
he was a rubber stamp for the project
basically truman simply assumed the bomb
would be used when ready
he didn't even give a specific order for
the first two bombs to be
dropped and after the first two bombs it
was ordered that no more would be
dropped without his explicit permission
to do so
which of course implies that they didn't
need that permission beforehand
we can see something of an abdication of
responsibility among those behind the
nuclear bomb
in his memoirs truman states i had
realized of course that the atomic bomb
explosion would inflict damage and
casualties beyond imagination
on the other hand the scientific
advisers of the committee reported
we can propose no technical
demonstration likely to bring an end to
the war
we see no acceptable alternative to
direct military use
it was their conclusion that no
technical demonstration they might
propose
such as over a deserted island would be
likely to bring the war to an end
it had to be used against an enemy
target
on the other hand several top manhattan
project scientists including oppenheimer
made efforts to distance themselves from
what they claimed was merely a military
decision
in a report issued on the 16th of june
they stated that we have no claim to
special competence in solving the
political social and military problems
which are presented by the advent of
atomic power
oppenheimer also later stated that we
didn't know beans about the military
situation in japan
we didn't know whether they could be
caused to surrender by other means or
whether the invasion was really
inevitable
so truman's sharing responsibility with
the scientists here saying well i knew
the bomb was going to be horrible
obviously but these scientists told me a
peaceful demonstration would never work
and that i had to drop it on a city so
you know and the scientists are saying
hey well what are you listening to us
for we don't know
we're physicists we just built the thing
we don't know about foreign policy or
military strategy
there's a sense that nobody's really in
control of this thing
the ball was rolling and nobody had the
inclination to stop it
i would like to add however that
regardless of any of this truman
is still responsible here and he still
made a decision
even if it was more of a passive
decision than an active one
now all this has led some to wonder
about whether or not the bombs would
have been used had president roosevelt
not died when he did
albert einstein who i'm told was a
rather smart guy
in certain regards came to this
conclusion stating that
the use of the atomic bombs was
precipitated by a desire to end the war
in the pacific by any means before
russia's participation
i'm sure if president roosevelt had
still been there none of that would have
been possible
so as we've seen the bombs were dropped
for a combination
of many reasons but none of these was to
avoid an invasion of japan
by the time it was an option to drop
nuclear bombs on japan
an invasion was already off the table it
was no longer necessary
both truman and burns thought that japan
was going to surrender because
of the upcoming russian declaration of
war and the bombs were dropped
in part to attempt to force a surrender
prior to that
before we wrap up today we should ask
where did this invasion narrative come
from
why is it the enduring popular
perception of events
let's return to the start of the video
and talk again about what i called the
trolley problem version of events
now i have a confession to make about
this what i do when i want to find an
example of a poor
argument put forward ineptly is go and
check if prager university has ever made
a video on the topic
and would you know it they have made one
about the nuclear bombs titled
was it wrong to drop the atom bomb on
japan which of course concludes it was
completely justified
and the version of events written at the
start of my video
is constructed almost entirely out of
statements made in their video so
that's right this was a stealth prageru
response video this whole time what a
twist
so this prageru video starts out by
giving far too much agency to a certain
mr president truman when they say
truman sought to bomb hiroshima and
nagasaki two major military industrial
targets to avoid an
invasion of japan so they're assigning
to truman the decision of which
targets to bomb there now truman had no
input on deciding to target hiroshima or
nagasaki he didn't even know nagasaki
was going to be bombed until after it
already had been
nagasaki wasn't even the target city of
the plane that dropped the bomb
on nagasaki it only got attacked because
the primary target was too cloudy to hit
now i could pick through this video line
by line giving rebuttals like this to
each of its claims but this video is
long enough already so instead i just
want to focus on two quotes that concern
the bombs versus invasion narrative
and the first is this it was only the
dropping of the atom bombs that allowed
the emperor
and the so-called peace faction in the
japanese government
to negotiate an end to the war now this
is just a total
inversion of reality the atom bombs did
not allow the emperor to negotiate and
enter the war
either with the united states or within
his own government
the problem was not that prior to the
bombs japan was refusing to negotiate
an end to the war it's that they were
insisting on negotiating an
end to the war the united states was the
country refusing to negotiate an end to
the war
because they were insisting on
unconditional surrender
and the emperor didn't negotiate and
enter the war within his own government
he was the emperor the government did
what he said
the militarists wanted to fight to the
death even after the nuclear bombs were
dropped
there was no negotiation there was no
convincing them
it was a deadlock broken by the
emperor's divine
ruling this idea that the japanese
leadership were committed
to total war only until the bombs forced
them to the negotiating table
is entirely false i also have a
particular distaste for the phrasing
it was only the dropping of the atom
bomb because imperial japan was beaten
long before the nuclear bombs were
dropped and pretending that it took the
nuclear bombs to defeat japan is not
only
untrue it's a dangerous exaggeration it
makes the empire of japan into such a
powerful enemy that you need nuclear
force to take them down
and it covers up the reality which is
that imperial japan was already a
defeated state run by
incompetent ignorant leaders the next
quote i want to talk about
is this all the viable alternate
scenarios to secure american victory
all would have meant significantly
greater american and allied casualties
and
much higher japanese civilian and
military casualties
according to american military estimates
at the time those numbers would have
been well above
1 million now you may have noticed today
that we have not thus far discussed what
the projected wartime casualties of a
full allied invasion of japan were going
to be
and that's because until after the war
there were no such projections made
this quote from prageru here is a lie
the enormously high death estimates for
a full invasion of japan were
entirely a post-war fabrication now
before we talk about where this one
million figure came from i'd like to
remind everyone that an invasion was
unnecessary and not going to happen
anyway whatever death estimates you come
up with a thousand
a million a hundred million it does not
matter
an invasion was not going to happen and
the bombs were not
used to avert it right so with that in
mind
this one million figure comes from an
article published in henry stimson's
name in harper's magazine
in 1947. this article was written in
response to various criticisms of the
use of the atomic bomb which had begun
emerging after the end of the war and it
was edited by various people responsible
for the bomb
including general leslie groves the
article lays out the trolley problem
excuse
we simply had to do the nuclear bombs it
argues there was no
other way talking about the apparently
inevitable invasion
the article states i was informed that
such operations might be expected to
cost over a million
casualties to american forces alone now
as i've already stated
there is no evidence of such an estimate
being made prior to the end of the war
and president truman at no point
presented the nuclear bombs as an
alternative to an allied invasion of
japan
until he had to justify the use of the
bombs after the war
only then did the invasion become
inevitable
and did the death estimates shoot up
into the millions
this is where the atom bombs vs invasion
narrative comes from
after the bomb was dropped the u.s
leadership started telling
lies about it president truman himself
got started very early on august 9th
1945 when he addressed the nation with a
speech
seeking to justify the use of the
nuclear bomb
and i quote the world will note that the
first atomic bomb was dropped on
hiroshima
a military base that was because we
wished in this first attack to avoid
insofar as possible the killing of
civilians
now this is a lie obviously hiroshima
was a city
the bomb's target committee describes it
as a city remember that hiroshima has
the advantage of being such a size that
a large fraction of the city may be
destroyed and truman's lying continues
as follows
but that attack is only a warning of
things to come
if japan does not surrender bombs will
have to be dropped on her war industries
and unfortunately thousands of civilian
lives will be lost
i urge japanese civilians to leave
industrial cities immediately
and save themselves from destruction so
truman isn't justifying the bombing of
hiroshima by saying
it was a city with several war
industries in it which is what the
eventual excuse came to be
he's going for broke here and saying it
was solely
a military base and that unless japan
surrenders bombs will have to be dropped
on her war industries
implying that that has not happened
already averting an invasion was not
given as a reason for using the bombs in
this speech because they hadn't come up
with that excuse yet
truman also here claims the bomb was
used to spare the lives of
thousands and thousands not the later
claimed millions and millions
another lie that became popular after
the war was that the nuclear bomb was
dropped in response to japan ignoring
the potsdam declaration
however the only existing direct order
to go ahead with the use of the nuclear
bombs against japan was issued prior to
the potsdam declaration
not by truman of course he didn't have
anything to do with it
it was drafted by leslie groves approved
by henry stimson
and delivered to general carl spatz
commander of the strategic air forces on
july the 25th
the day before the potsdam declaration
was issued
they did not wait for a response before
issuing the order to proceed with the
atomic bombings
the order was issued before japan had
even seen the surrender terms
as a result of these lies and others the
simplified version of the history came
into existence
and it isn't hard to understand why this
caught on
firstly it took me two minutes at the
top of the video to explain the easy lie
and the whole rest of the video to
explain the much more complicated truth
the bombs versus invasion narrative is
simple
it's plausible and it's easy to
understand
it isn't true of course but why let that
get in the way of a good story
but the invasion narrative is not just
easier to understand
it's also easier to accept because if we
question it
we have to contend with the possibility
or the certainty
that the united states of america
incinerated two cities full of innocent
civilians for no good reason
given the enormous death toll the truth
that the use of the bombs was pointless
and accomplished nothing is very
difficult to accept
now it's about time for me to conclude
this video here
and trying to neatly sum up such a
complicated event with so
many actors all with their own
contradictory motivations is surely an
exercise in frustration there is no
doing it justice that said the nuclear
bombs used against japan were an
expensive gamble that did not
pay off they were dropped on civilians
intentionally
per the flawed strategy of morale
bombing to force japan to surrender
unconditionally
before the soviet union joined the war
in this they were a complete failure the
lie that the bombs were used only to
avert an
invasion of japan was a post-war
construction
intended to provide justification for a
completely avoidable
and indefensible slaughter of innocent
civilians
the civilians who died in hiroshima and
nagasaki were not
killed to avert an invasion of japan nor
did they bravely give their lives in
sacrifice to save their empire
their deaths were entirely unnecessary
and we owe it to them
to admit that often when terrible
injustices towards the inhabitants of
one country are discussed the response
will come
well what about all the terrible
injustices carried out by that country
to other people this is a question that
has varying motivations behind it of
varying legitimacy on the one hand
certain events from the second world war
and wider history in general i suppose
do get much more attention
and discussion for whatever reasons than
other events of equal importance
and it is perfectly valid to ask that we
do not forget that imperial japan
committed many terrible war crimes and
was both during and before the war a
brutal totalitarian oppressor of many
different people
i think it's very important to make
clear here that nothing we've talked
about today should generate
any sympathy whatsoever for imperial
japan as a concept
or the leadership of the imperial
japanese government or military
the crimes of the empire of japan were
dreadful
and there is no punishment that
perpetrators would not deserve
and many of these crimes it is worth
pointing out have went either ignored or
unapologized for by the japanese
government to this day
all that being said we must be careful
to accurately allocate
fault here because unfortunately that
same question
what about all the stuff they did it's
not always asked with such innocent
intentions
sometimes this question reveals
something very worrisome
and that's the belief in racial crimes
that can be avenged with violence
towards other members of that group
and this is the worst sort of us versus
them thinking
they did something bad to us so they
and by they i mean anyone i reckon is in
that group
deserves something bad in return so
while we should have no sympathy
whatsoever
for the empire of japan the school
children of hiroshima and
nagasaki were not the empire of japan
they were some school children they had
nothing to do with pearl harbor
they did not consent to go to war they
were needlessly put in danger by one
power
and needlessly killed by another nothing
was avenged or
paid back there was no point to it but
to provide
yet more evidence that there's no
monopoly held by any nation or race on a
disregard
for the lives of the powerless
thanks a lot for watching everyone if
you enjoyed this video please consider
clicking the subscribe
button so you'll be informed of future
videos which hopefully won't all be this
long and take
quite so long to come out and thank you
in particular to my wonderful supporters
over on patreon for supporting me while
i make videos like this one and
providing
very useful feedback i'm currently
accepting suggestions for future video
topics on my patreon page so if you have
anything in particular you would like to
suggest
you can head over to the patreon link in
the video description
and let me know right thanks a lot folks
i'll see you next time